nous avons désigné hier matin deux
rapporteurs de la commission des lois le
président sueur et madame muriel jourda
ils interviennent au titre de la mission
d'information que nous avons constitué
et dans le périmètre détermine les
pouvoirs d'investigation que nous avons
obtenu du sénat les auditions de la
commission son public
ce qui veut dire qu'ils qu'elles sont
ouvertes à la presse est ouverte au
public dans la limite des places
disponibles
bien entendu les sénateurs non membre de
la commission des lois sont les
bienvenus à ces auditions
nombreux sont présents d'ailleurs ils ne
peuvent en principe poser de questions
mais je suis prêt à permettre une
question par groupe
après les questions des rapporteurs et
les questions des membres de la
commission des lois les questions qui
sont posées
chers collègues non membre de la
commission des lois par vous mêmes n'ont
pas le statut de questions sous le
régime de la commission denquête je vous
le précise le temps de chaque question
sera limitée à une minute pour vous
faciliter la tâche nous avons installé
un compteur
l'objet de nos auditions et en
particulier de celle de monsieur le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
et triple vérifier la réalité des faits
lever les contradictions qui ont pu
apparaître dans les réponses apportées
par les différentes personnalités qui
ont déjà été à deux positionnés par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale pour celle des personnalités
qui auront déjà était auditionné ou des
réponses qui auront été publiquement
apporté en dehors de ces commission
denquête et apporter des précisions
quant il ne sera apparu qu'un certain
nombre de réponses comportait trop de
conditionnel de semble-t-il ou
d'approximations deuxièmement soulever
toutes les questions sur les
dysfonctionnements et les violations de
la répartition des pouvoirs
constitutionnels entre le président de
la république et le gouvernement
seule autorité qui est responsable de
l'administration
en vertu de l'article 20 de la
constitution
troisièmement enfin soulever toutes les
questions sur l'organisation de la
sécurité du président de la république
qui dans un régime républicain n'est pas
une affaire privée mais une affaire
d'état qui doit être assumée par des
professionnels sélectionnés formé
qualifié entraîné coordonné par ceux
dont c'est la compétence je laisse bien
sûr la possibilité aux personnalités
convoquées d'ouvrir leur propre audition
par un propos liminaire que le
souhaitent bref je poserai ensuite moi
même s'il y a lieu quelques questions
auxquelles je l'inviterai à répondre
aussitôt je donnerais ensuite la parole
à chacun des rapporteurs qui poseront à
leur tour leurs questions
le la personne auditionnée répondra
question par question aux questions
posées sans les groupes et les questions
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure devons être
formulée en moins d'une minute et ainsi
je crois que nos travaux permettront à
chacun d'entre vous chers collègues et
pas priorité aux membres de la
commission des lois de d'obtenir toutes
les réponses qu'ils attendent et dont
nous apprécierons ultérieurement le
contenu
monsieur le ministre d'état comme je lai
annoncé je dois vous demander de prêter
serment
j'ai rappelé et je me dois de le faire
qu'un faute et je les fais pour chacune
de nos auditions je tiens à vous le
préciser qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission et pénalement
sanctionnables
je vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure je vous donne la parole mme smith
et à merci bien monsieur le président de
la commission des lois
madame messieurs les co rapporteurs
j'ai longtemps été dans cette commission
des lois je ne pensais pas y revenir
dans de telles circonstances
mais l'on se fait à tout je tiens en
introduction de cette audition à vous
dire ma volonté d'apporter au sénat
comme je lé fais hier à l'assemblée
nationale tous les éléments susceptibles
de l'éclairer sur l'objet de cette
mission relative vous l'avez rappelé aux
conditions auxquelles les personnes
n'appartenant pas aux forces de sécurité
intérieure ont pu être autorisés ou
associés à l'exercice de missions de
maintien de l'ordre et de protection des
autres personnalités avant tout je tiens
à redire une nouvelle fois que je
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté les
actes auxquels ses livres et monsieur
benallal le 1er mai
dernier ils sont inacceptables et son
jeu lady contraire à mes valeurs à ce
que j'ai toujours défendues dans mes
différentes responsabilités à ce que je
défends
maintenant en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président notre
objectif est donc le même pour vous
comme pour moi la transparence la vérité
j'en viens donc sans attendre à ce qui
s'est passé le 1er mai et je le
réaffirme il n'appartient à personne en
dehors des forces de sécurité de gérer
l'ordre public
je commencerai donc pas redressé à
nouveau une chronologie très précise des
faits ce 1er mai aurait pu être un 1er
mai si je puis dire traditionnel axée
sur les revendications syndicales
mais un certain nombre d'individus en
avait décidé autrement et la lettre vous
le savez extrêmement violent en effet
dès le début de la manifestation se
forment un avant cortège plus important
que le cortège lui-même avec au milieu
d'où 100 black blocs qui se cagouler ils
traversent le pont e d'austerlitz et
gagne le boulevard de l'hôpital où il se
livre un déferlement de violence
saccageant plusieurs commerces un
mcdonald's est un concessionnaire
automobile
je crois que tous les français ont
encore dans l'esprit ces images qui
étaient d'une violence totalement inouï
grâce un dispositif de maintien de
l'ordre important 15 cents policiers
gendarmes
la progression et fauteur de trouble est
stoppée mais une partie d'entre eux a
lancé le mot d'ordre de poursuivre la
casse place de la contrescarpe il
voulait dans leur projet initial aller
jusqu'au commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement que nous venions et
d'inaugurer il y avait quinze jours de
manière à pouvoir
l'incendié ils ont été stoppés mais il
se retrouve à la contrer ça à 19h30
je me trouve à la préfecture de police
pour faire un débriefing opérationnel
sur les événements de la journée avec le
préfet de police dans son bureau
nous gagnons ensuite ensemble la salle
de commandement pour suivre les
affrontements qui se poursuivent alors
place de la contrescarpe nousallons la
quarantaine de personnes présentes parmi
lesquelles monsieur benalla dont je le
répète aujourd'hui je pensais alors
qu'il était un policier chargé de la
sécurité du président je l'avais en
effet comme je les dis croisés pendant
la campagne présidentielle
mais il était toujours parmi des
dizaines de personnes chargées de la
sécurité du candidat policiers agents de
sécurité service d'ordre dans marche
monsieur gibelin et son adjoint me faut
une présentation du dispositif
puis nous fixons un autre attention sur
les écrans car les violences continuent
avec l'utilisation de mobilier urbain et
vous savez qu'à paris et en a en ce
moment beaucoup pour tenté d'ériger des
barricades et des interpellations sont
toujours en cours notamment dans le
secteur de la contrescarpe comme l'a dit
hier le préfet de police
il y assure la journée du 1er mai
environ deux cent soixante seize
interpellations dont trente et une sur
la seule place de la contrescarpe les
opérations est terminée je rentre à
beauvau puis à 23 heures je me rends
avec le premier ministre et le préfet de
police au commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement de paris
celui dont je vous ai dit qu'il était la
cible les black blocks
nous saluons les troupes présentes et
avant une discussion avec elle sur les
événements de la journée
le lendemain matin 2 mai dès 7h30
je participe à l'émission les 4 vérités
sur france 2 où j'ai eu l'occasion de
revenir sur les événements de la veille
et leur gestion par les forces de
l'ordre
à 8h30 revenant de cette émission je
préside une réunion d'états majors avec
les principales directions du ministère
où nous évoquons les événements qui ont
émaillé le 1er mai au moment où l'ordre
du jour concernant le 1er mai est épuisé
je laisse la présidence mon directeur de
cabinet et vais m'entretenir après avec
la directrice de la police judiciaire
avec le directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure pour faire un point sur la
menace terroriste qui elle aussi nous
semblait extrêmement important je ne
croise donc pas à ce moment là le préfet
de police à la réunion d'état major où
il est représenté par ses collaborateurs
mais je lui fait savoir que je souhaite
me rendre avec lui boulevard de
l'hôpital pour à la fois me rendre
compte par moi même de l'itinéraire
emprunté à part l'anif manifestation de
la façon dont la manoeuvre a été
effectué et aussi pour évaluer les
dégâts causés
nous nous entretenons alors avec les
commerçants qui nous raconte des faits
d'une extrême violence et en particulier
le concessionnaire qui avait vu ses
voitures incendiées nous raconte les
choses absolument insensé elle nous dit
à ce moment là j'ai eu véritablement
très peur le préfet de police leur dit
qu'ils vont être indemnisé dans les
meilleurs délais à ce moment là ni le
préfet de police ni mon cabinet ne m'ont
encore informé d'une vidéo montrant des
violences contre les manifestants
place de la contrescarpe à l'issue j'ai
un déjeuner avec un membre de ma famille
dans un restaurant de la rue de lille ce
n'est qu'à mon retour aux ministères aux
alentours de 15 à que mon directeur et
mon chef de cabinet m'apprennent de
l'existence de la vidéo et m'apprennent
que les violences ont été commises par
monsieur benalla dont j'apprends alors
qu'il n'était pas comme je le pense
policiers mais chargé de mission à
l'elysée se présentant
mais lui seul comme le chef de cabinet
adjoint du président de la république
mon directeur de cabinet mme assure
alors que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république c'est à dire
le supérieur hiérarchique de monsieur
benalla et le préfet de police
connaissent les faits ils s'en sont
entretenus ensemble c'est lui aussi qui
ma vie ce que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république lui a
confirmé dans la soirée qu'il je suis
considéré l'action de monsieur benalla
comme inacceptable et qu'une sanction
disciplinaire allait être pris
j'apprendrai beaucoup plus tard le 21
juillet que le préfet de police avait
fait rédiger une autre technique sur les
faits qui l'a reconnu lui-même ne
m'avoir jamais transmis ce 3 mai je
considère donc que les faits sont pris
en compte au niveau adapté à partir de
ce jour-là et jusqu'au 18 juillet je
n'entends plus parler de monsieur
benalla je me concentre alors sur
d'autres évènements gestion le lendemain
et 3 mai d'une manifestation cheminots
de la préparation du rassemblement du
samedi 5 mai organisé par la france
insoumise afin que les choses ne
dégénèrent pas comme elle l'avait fait
pour le 1er mai je prépare les
évacuations des facultés de toulouse le
mirail le 9 mai de rennes le 14 mai je
prépare la deuxième évacuation de notre
dame des landes
enfin je gère malheureusement les suites
de l'attentât de paris 2e et fera vous
le savez une victime le samedi 12 mai
jean vient désormais la journée du 18
juillet
ce jour là j'apprends dans l'après midi
vers 15 heures que des journalistes du
monde prépare un article sur les
événements du 1er mai qui paraît aux
alentours de 20h30 le lendemain matin je
prends connaissance des images parues
sur les réseaux sociaux
montrant que monsieur benalla portait le
1er mai un brassard de police et qu'il
détenait une radio je demande donc
immédiatement
qu'on prépare une saisie de l'igpn pour
déterminer les conditions dans
lesquelles il a pu bénéficier de tels
équipements
entre temps j'ai un rendez vous avec
monsieur jean pierre chevènement
président de la fondation pour l'islam
de france que je prépare avec une demi
conseillère et j'ai ensuite un déjeuner
avec des journalistes et à 15 heures
lors des questions au gouvernement au
sénat
j'annonce que nous allons saisir l'igpn
à mon retour
j'apprends que trois policiers de la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation ont donnés à monsieur
benalla les banques de vidéo protection
des événements de la contrescarpe nous
transmettons ces nouvelles informations
à l'igpn et le matin du 20 juillet je
suspends sur proposition du préfet de
police
les trois policiers concernés voilà donc
mesdames et messieurs la chronologie
précise des faits tels que je les ai
vécues ces précisions chronologique
apporter je souhaiterais dans un second
temps éclaircir quelques points
certains après mon audition à
l'assemblée nationale se sont étonnés
que je n'ai pas eu connaissance de
certains faits les auditions et du
préfet de police du directeur de l'ordre
public et de la circulation dans la même
journée ont montré qu'aucun d'eux qui
pourtant était au coeur de la manoeuvre
n'avait été ni informée est de la
participation de monsieur benalla aux
opérations d'ordre public ni de sa venue
au centre de commandement de la
préfecture de police
comment dès lors si ceux là même qui
effectivement été à la manoeuvre ne
connaissais pas aurais-je pu savoir sur
le port d'ars je confirme que monsieur
benalla s'était tourné en janvier 2017
vers mon prédécesseur pour solliciter
une autorisation et lui avait été
refusée le 12 abris le 21 juin 2017
il s'était de nouveau adressé à mes
services pour que sa demande soit
réétudié demande à laquelle mon cabinet
n'avait pas donné suite considérant que
les conditions juridiques n'étaient pas
réunies comme l'a dit le préfet de
police
ce sont donc ces services par lui
directement qui ont finalement attribué
à monsieur benalla une autorisation de
port d'armes délivré le 13 octobre 2010
est sans que mon cabinet en aient été
informés
pour ce qui est de l'article 40 je pense
que on y reviendra dans les débats je
m'en tiens à ce que j'ai dit hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
comme je lé rappeler je vous donnerai
tout à l'heure quelques exemples les
ministres de l'intérieur successifs ont
évidemment eu connaissance par les
services de renseignements de multiples
suspicion d'infraction pénale ou de
commission d'infractions pénales mais
comme mes prédécesseurs je considère que
c'est aux chefs de service à ceux qui
sont au plus près du terrain
recueillant les éléments permettant de
justifier la transmission d'un
signalement au titre de l'article 40 de
le faire je n'en ai d'ailleurs transmis
qu'un seul depuis mon arrivée tout à
l'heure je vous dirai combien monte mes
prédécesseurs en ont transmis il
concernait la vidéo d'un rappeur
appelant au lynchage et au meurtre d'un
policier
j'ai demandé à la direction des libertés
publiques et des affaires juridiques
d'établir la liste des articles 40
transmis par les anciens ministres de
l'intérieur
je vous la donnerai tout à l'heure il
ressort que aussi en ont fait très peu
et qu'ils concernent essentiellement des
infractions relatives à la loi de 1881
sur la liberté de la presse
dernier point pourquoi n'avoir pas saisi
dès le 2 mai à l'igpn
comme je voulais dît j'apprends le 2 mai
que monsieur benalla n'était pas
policier je n'ai donc pas de raison
alors de saisir l'igpn
le préfet de police qui savait lui qu'il
n'était pas policier partage cette année
is sur le fait qu' il a il l'a dit lui
même il à réunir les chefs de service et
leur dit comment se fait-il que cet
homme qui effectivement n'a aucune
permission de ma part pour participer à
une mission d'ordre public y participent
effectivement c'est donc seulement après
avoir appris que monsieur beynat la
porte et indûment le 1er mai un brassard
et qu'il détenait une radio de police
qui lui avait été remis par on verra
dans l' enquête quel service que je
saisi l'igpn
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voilà ce que je souhaite vous dire les
éléments que je souhaite porter à votre
connaissance et vous me permettrez de
conclure comme vous l'avez fait monsieur
le président en soulignant que nous
devons la vérité aux français mais aussi
que nous la devons aux forces de l'ordre
qui eux agissent avec nous le rappelons
toujours un souci de la déontologie et
nous leur demandons nous leur rappelons
s'est inscrit dès les écoles de
formation
voilà mesdames et messieurs c'est les
sénateurs je suis prêt maintenant à
répondre à vos différentes questions sur
le ministre d'état
ma première question mais directement
inspirées par les auditions auxquelles
nous avons procédé cet après midi des
différents syndicats de policiers et de
commissaires de police
tous sans exception nous ont dit leur
indignation nous l'ont dit à quel point
ils ont été blessées de l'image qui est
donnée de la police par un faux policier
combien ils ont été humiliés d'apprendre
les moyens exorbitants dans cette
personne a pu disposer combien ils ont
été choqués que l'image de la police ait
pu ainsi être ternie comme s'il s'était
agi d'une bavure policière
c'est leur expression ils ont également
exprimé leur inquiétude sur la prise en
charge de la sécurité du président de la
république et sur les évolutions qui ont
été annoncés en ce début d'année 2010 8
ils nous ont dit avec franchise que les
langues se déliaient que leurs adhérents
les informer de ce qui était c'était
réellement produit ils savent que
monsieur benalla était régulièrement
présent à des réunions de la préfecture
de police
ils savent aussi que monsieur benalla
dans ses activités aux services de la
présidence de la république et pour la
protection du chef de l'état avait un
comportement que plusieurs d'entre eux
ont qualifiées de déplacées voire
d'injurieux ils ont observé que il avait
une fâcheuse tendance à donner des
instructions aux cadres de police ou de
gendarmerie placés sous votre autorité
je comprends
que vous nous ayez indiqué que vous
n'aviez pourtant jamais entendu parler
de ces dysfonctionnements
jusqu'à découvrir les dysfonctionnements
du 1er mai et cela avez vous dit le 2
mai après midi mais les syndicats de
policiers nous ont également dit avec la
plus extrême netteté et j'ai pris soin
de leur demander de doute il tenait
cette information qu'il y avait et je
reprends leur expression exacte des
groupes de vigiles qui était associé au
groupement de la présidence de la
république pour la sécurité du chef de
l'état à l'elysée
monsieur le ministre d'état ma première
question est est-ce vrai et ma deuxième
question si c'est vrai est ce que c'est
normal
monsieur le président d'abord je veux
vous rappeler qu'avant mon arrivée au
ministère de l'intérieur il y avait des
tensions assez fortes avec la police et
que nous avions eu à l'époque c'était
quelques mois avant les policiers en
colère chacun sans doute s'en souvient
ici j'ai passé les premiers mois de mon
ministère à tisser des relations de
confiance avec les différents syndicats
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ces relations
de confiance sont fortes
lorsque j'ai par exemple élaboré la
police de sécurité du quotidien c'est
avec une personne qui était responsable
monsieur mise et à ce n'est pas exact
préliminaire dès votre réponse je fais
tout ce sont les préliminaires
je vous remercie si ceci est
préliminaire est ce sont les
préliminaires monsieur barry mais comme
vous faites vous même des préliminaires
je suis obligé d'en faire un effet des
préliminaires qu'après les vôtres et
vous refaites des préliminaires joie
l'asu lyon raison et l'un et l'autre des
prix alors nous annoncer vos évènements
effectivement que nous avons un sens de
la phrase nous allons passer un accord
pour ne plus faire de peli mais alors je
suis d'accord avec vous donc ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que pour moi les
relations de confiance avec les
policiers et les gendarmes à tous
niveaux que ce soit sont effectivement
extrêmement important sur la réforme qui
pouvait être annoncé
c'est vrai qu'un travail de
réorganisation de l'ensemble des
services administratifs de l'elysée a
été lancée il ya plusieurs mois en
matière de sécurité la situation
actuelle était la suivante avec d'un
côté le groupe de sécurité de la
présidence de la
république gspr qui assure la sécurité
du président pendant les visites
officielles avec la première compagnie
républicaine de sécurité crs 1 et de
l'autre le commandement militaire qui
assure la sécurité du président dans le
palais avec la préfecture de police
cela crée des situations inextricables
par exemple les systèmes de
communication entre les uns et les
autres ne sont pas compatibles
inefficace ce ne sont pas les même
doctrine d'action coûteuse
c'est le rapport de la cour des comptes
sans compter les tâches indues dont
s'acquittent les deux services
le gspr gère les bagages de la
délégation lors d'un voyage officiel à
l'international tandis que le
commandement militaire gère le service
de veille bresse ces deux éléments et
j'en arrive au point qui vous
intéressent ont conduit à réfléchir mais
tout cela je pense vous intéresse aussi
à la fusion du gspr et du commandement
militaire pour créer une direction de la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république
d s p r il s'agit donc purement d'un
enjeu de rationalisation des ressources
et des emplois pas de création d'autres
services cette accusation ne peut pas
tenir
selon l'elysée cette réflexion était
piloté par monsieur lavernhe du gspr et
monsieur bio-farina commandant militaire
et pour moi il n'a jamais été question
qu'alexandre benalla prennent la tête de
la structure
des bruits ont pu courir
effectivement je ne savais pas en tout
cas que guy si j'ai appris après je les
les histoires les pommes d'organisation
du gspr on en a discuté depuis quelques
instants
monsieur le président merci monsieur
discuter ou encore il y avait je le
rappelle ce ministre déjà je vous
répondrais monsieur ministre derrida des
questions mais nous n'avons pas encore
posé et vous ne répondez pas à la
question posée au sol je la répète les
syndicats de policiers nous ont indiqué
monsieur le ministre d'état qu'il y
avait des groupes de vigiles privés
travaillant au sein du j'espère
actuellement je vous ai demandé est ce
vrai et si c'est vrai est ce normal
c'est une question très très simple vous
devez répondre que la connaissance il
n'y a aucun vigile qui travaille au
service du j espère qu est un service
officielle serait ce normal de votre
point de vue qu'il y ait des effectifs
privés qui travaillent au centre
j'espère pour moi travail aujourd'hui et
comme vous le savez il ya une relation
entre le gspr de service de protection
des personnalités officielles
c'est effectivement nous avons sur le ch
et espère une relation here are chic
mais c'est à dire que c'est nous qui
effectivement nommé au ministère de
l'intérieur
mais ensuite pour ce qui est de l'usaj
fonctionnel c'est effectivement la
présidence de la république que cela
s'organise sans qu'il y ait de
responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur
mais c'est vrai de manière globale sur
effectivement toutes les présidences de
la république
serait-il normal monsieur le ministre
d'état qu'il y eu au sein du gspr des
agents qui auraient des responsabilités
opérationnelles pour la protection du
chef de l'état et qui ne serait ni
policier ni gendarme au sein du gspr à
ma connaissance il n'y a que les
policiers et les gendarmes
monsieur le ministre d'état really accru
les policiers et les gendarmes c'est la
réponse que je peux vous faire
est ce que ce serait normal qu'il y ait
des contractuels privé qui ne soit ni
policier ni gendarme
pour moi le j'espère ce sont les
policiers les gens et je vous remercie
j'ai une deuxième question monsieur le
ministre d'état on va essayer d'aller un
petit peu plus vite si vous le voulez
bien vous êtes sur le plan politique
l'un des responsables politiques les
plus proches du président macron vous
êtes dans la hiérarchie gouvernementale
le numéro 2 le 2 mai muni des
informations que vous recevez vous avez
le réflexe dites-vous d'informer la
présidence de la république qui est déjà
au courant mais monsieur le ministre
d'état vous trop protégé minéraux
protéger le chef de l'état y compris
comme l'un de ses plus fidèles soutiens
politiques avez vous fait une démarche
pour l'alerter sur la gravité de cette
situation
avez-vous recueillies à partir de cette
date du 2 mai des informations
complémentaires sur le comportement dont
nous avons connaissance de monsieur
bénard dans ses relations avec les
services de sécurité et lui avez-vous
fait les recommandations nécessaires
pour qu'il mette un terme à cette
collaboration sans se contenter de la
mise à pied qui a été prononcée est-ce
que vous ne considérez pas que c'était
en quelque sorte votre devoir en
fonction d'une analyse politique
monsieur le ministre dileita de l'alerté
pour qu'il mette fin à cette
collaboration si dangereuse comme la
suite l'arrivée des comme vous en
souvenez sans doute monsieur le
président et se trouve que ce jour là le
président de la république était en
australie donc à cellou est rentré de ce
qui se passait le premier est donc
immédiatement lorsque nous avons eu
connaissance des faits mon directeur de
cabinet alerte le directeur de cabinet
de
l'elysée qui l'a dit et je vous ai cité
la phrase exacte tout à l'heure qu'il
jugeait cette attitude inacceptable et
qu'il prendrait des sanctions et donc à
partir de là c'est au directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
qu'il appartient de prendre les
sanctions qu'il juge appropriés je vous
rappelle que monsieur benalla n'était
aucunement sous ma responsabilité
merci monsieur 2010 d'étape donc que
vous n'avez pas profité d'un entretien
avec le président de la république pour
le mettre en garde et l'alerté sur le
comportement de son collaborateur et lui
recommander dans la mesure si vous ne me
paraissait nécessaire à l'heure j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de syndicats de
police
beaucoup de syndicat de commissaires
personne ne m'a jamais fait remonter
dans une quelconque réunion
les problèmes pourraient rencontrer bien
alors je poursuis parce qu'il faut que
chacun puisse poser ces questions à les
rapporteurs en premier avez vous adressé
des instructions immédiates à la
hiérarchie administrative policière et
militaire passée sous votre autorité
pour que l'effet kiss qui sont survenus
le 1er mai ne se reproduise pas le comme
vous le savez évidemment que nous
alertons chaque fois l'ensemble des
préfets pour qu'ils aient une attitude
qui fasse que le comportement de nos
policiers soient effectivement
exemplaires je les fais j'ai envie mon
directeur de cabinet a dû envoyer une
vingtaine de recommandations parce que
comme vous le savez nous avons vécu des
temps troublés
c'était relativement difficile d'exercer
l'ordre public vous souvenez par exemple
que lors de l'évacuation de la fac de
tall blacks de tolbiac une fake news
avait circulé disant que quelqu'un avait
été mis
elle était en sang donc nous nous avons
alerté nos policiers il s'est révélé
ensuite que c'était une fille news et
que la personne qui avait devant les
télévisions raconter tout cela avait
totalement menti et inventé cette scène
donc moi j'essaye de prendre les choses
sur les faits et non pas simplement sur
les visions telles qu'elles peuvent être
racontée donc pas d'instructions données
aux services de police et de gendarmerie
pour éviter les interférences de
collaborateurs du président de la
république avec le fonctionnement normal
de la hiérarchie de la police et de la
hiérarchie de la gendarmerie
pour ce qui concerne et vous le savez
donc le préfet de police de paris
puisqu'il s'agit du comportement de
monsieur benalla il
je sais pas si vous l'avez encore
auditionné cet après midi mais la dire à
l'assemblée nationale il a à ce moment
là réuni l'ensemble donc de ses
commandants pour leur faire passer un
certain nombre de recommandations dire
que personne ne devait effectivement
assisté à une manoeuvre sans que lui
même les personnellement décidé et il a
ensuite proposé un certain nombre de
sanctions et les sanctions
qu'effectivement j'ai accepté madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre d'état donc sans
trop de préliminaires le préfet de
police de paris et le directeur de
l'ordre public la circulation monsieur
gibelin ollières indiqué devant
l'assemblée nationale que monsieur b
dallas n'avait pas reçu d'autorisation
officielle de participer en tant
qu'observateur aux opérations maintient
l'ordre du 1er mai ils ont également
précisé que la qualité d'observateur
avait été accordée à monsieur b dallas
par monsieur laurent simoneau chef
d'état major adjoint à la direction de
l'ordre public et la circulation socle
directeur lui-même n'en a été averti
première question est il normal que ni
le ministre de l'intérieur ni le préfet
de police ni même leurs cabines n en ait
été informé par ailleurs le ministère de
l'intérieur at-il dès le 2 mai diligenté
une enquête interne
pour obtenir des informations sur les
conditions de participation de monsieur
benalla à les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre
en effet vous avez indiqué que monsieur
b dallas ne participait pas des forces
de police mais il était sur l'opération
de maintien de l'ordre
cela signifie donc il avait été autorisé
bré semblablement par quelqu'un qui
appartenait à ses forces de police et ça
signifiait également si on en croit tous
les syndicats qu'il devait avoir un
référent en tant qu'observateur qui ne
s'est donc pas occupé de lui donc
aviez-vous diligenté une enquête interne
et enfin dans la négative pourquoi ne
pas vous être inquiétés d'un tel
dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre d'état comme je
viens de le dire a réuni l'ensemble de
ses cadres diligenter une enquête
enquête interne a demandé pourquoi lui
même n'avait pas été mise au courant
c'est dans ce cadre qu ensuite est
apparue la responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de cadres subalternes puisque
c'était en hiver au numéro 3 ou 4 qui
avait été prise la décision sans que le
préfet de police ne soit effectivement
informé de ce qui se passait c'est un
peu ces relations que le préfet de
police a décrit hier comme des copinages
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
le rapporteur pour l'instant pas
d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état je voulais vous poser
trois questions
d'abord eu s'agissant de l'application
dû code de procédure pénale vous avez
dit hier que il n'appartenait pas
finalement au ministre de l'intérieur d'
appliquer l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale
je voulais vous demander en vertu de
quels articles de la loi
vous pouvez faire cette affirmation
ensuite je peux comprendre que vous ayez
considérer qu'il revenait à d'autres
personnes qui avouent même de saisir la
justice devant la gravité évidente des
faits dont vous avez eu connaissance le
2 mai donc vous avez saisi le directeur
ou votre ministère votre directeur de
cabinet a saisi le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république mais celui
ci n'a pas plus que vous même et pas
plus que le préfet de police saisi le
ministère de la justice le procureur de
la république ni d'ailleurs le
secrétaire général de l'elysée ni
d'ailleurs le chef de cabinet du
président de la république est ce que
vous ne vous êtes pas dit logiquement au
bout d'un moment il ya quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas il y a
quelque chose de inacceptable et ça a
été dit depuis peu avec force
c'est à dire un personnage qui n'est pas
policier qui est connue qui se
comportent ainsi
ce qui à l'évidence et délictueux et
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur se
satisferaient du fait que personne
personne ne saisisse la justice c'est la
première question
ce ministre d'état s'il vous plaît alors
monsieur le co-rapporteur j'ai
connaissance quotidiennement par des
notes de service de renseignement de
suspicion d'infraction pénale ou de
commission d'infractions pénales
je considère et j'ai toujours considéré
depuis mon arrivée au ministère de
l'intérieur
et comme tous mes prédécesseurs qu'il
n'appartient pas au ministre de
l'intérieur de transmettre au procureur
des signalements sur le fondement de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à chaque fois qu'il a connaissance de la
commission d'une infraction pénale
ce n'est pas mon rôle de saisir chaque
procureur individuellement pour lui
signaler la commission d'infractions
je n'ai d'ailleurs transmis depuis ma
prise de fonction qu'un seul article 40
à la justice pour une infraction prévue
par la loi de 1881 de la presse il
concernait rappeur chez les dites à
l'heure dans une vidéo appelant ou la
salle et au meurtre d'un policier
alors ces pratiques sont elles
simplement celle du ministre de
l'intérieur actuel non j'ai regardé
combien
et avait été fait de signalement par les
différents ministres et les différentes
années sur l'année 2014 monsieur soeur
et on avait 2 sur l'année 2015 y en
avait 4 sur l'année 2016 il en avait 8
sur l'année 2016 y en a eu cap et là il
y en a eu un
et je regarde les différents ministres
l'ont ils fait non monsieur hortefeux
par exemple qu'il y avait un cabinet qui
d'un point de vue juridique avait
quelques expériences effectuées au cours
de l'année seulement trois signalements
au titre de l'article 40 et elles se
portent toutes sur des problèmes de
droit de la presse ou bien d'incitation
à l'air
je comprends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre d'état vous considérez qu'il ne
vous appartient pas de faire vous même
ces signalements pour autant vous citez
quand même des cas où le ministre l'a
fait et vous avez un pouvoir et
hiérarchique et si l'un de vos
collaborateurs vous demande
l'autorisation de faire un signalement
vous pouvez être amené à la lui donner
mais je vous rappelle les termes de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
sans les commenter plus avant toute
autorité constituée je crois que vous
êtes bien une autorité constituée qui
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
acquiert la connaissance d'un crime ou
d'un délit est tenu d'en donner avis
sans délai au procureur de la république
est rude et de transmettre à ce
magistrat tous les renseignements procès
revêt beau et actes qui y sont relatifs
je dois vous dire que la commission des
lois se serait parfaitement accommodés
que cette utilisation de l'article 40 ne
viennent pas de votre fait
nous ne vous reprocheront pas de ne pas
l'avoir fait personnellement mais du
constatons que dans toute la hiérarchie
personne ne l'a fait alors que de
nombreux cadres dirigeants du ministère
de l'intérieur avait en main les
éléments permettant de caractériser
cette suspicion de délit c'est c'est
simplement cela qui est derrière la
question je l'interprète
être de notre collègue le président
sueur mes paroles je veux vous rappeler
que le préfet de police et le directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
avait été informé de cette situation et
donc qu'il ne m'appartenait pas moi qui
ne connaissaient pas les circonstances
exactes puisque effectivement je n'ai
pas à connaître de la façon dont est
dirigée la préfecture de police de
prendre effectivement cet article
monsieur le ministre d'état que d'autres
que vous ai pu le faire c'est certain
mais que vous ne l'ayez pas fait pose
quand même question et si vous n'aviez
pas les informations nécessaires qui
aurait été mieux placé que vous pour les
obtenir
maintenant si vous le permettez monsieur
le président je voulais vous dire
monsieur le ministre vous employez
beaucoup le verbe connaître à la forme
négative
vous ne connaissiez pas vous ne saviez
pas mais je vous rappelle quand même les
termes de ma question dès lors que vous
considérez c'est une interprétation qui
est la vôtre qu'il ne revient pas au
ministre de l'intérieur de saisir la
justice
pourquoi ne vous êtes-vous pas étonné
que à aucun niveau de la hiérarchie dans
l'elysée au ministère de l'intérieur à
la préfecture de police personne ne les
faits mais j'en viens à ma deuxième
question le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république vous dit
qu'il va y avoir une sanction à l'égard
de monsieur bénalia il ya donc une
sanction puisqu'il est suspendu
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
pour 15 jours et monsieur le porte
parole de l'elysée dit qu'à la suite de
la suspension
il a été démis de toutes missions
relatives à la sécurité et à la
protection du président de la république
donc on lui a donné sans doute à notre
poste
alors vous ne connaissiez pas le et vous
l'avez dit je vous crois je n'ai pas de
raison de ne pas vous croire monsieur le
ministre d'état le chef de cabinet
adjoint de l'elysée vous vous rendez
compte qu'il existe le 2 mai bien qu'il
soit sûr quand même beaucoup de photos
et que le ministère de l'intérieur
quelques pouvoirs d'investigation on est
d'accord et vous dit vous vous faites
votre travail en informant monsieur
directeur de cabinet du président la
république
celui ci décide d'une sanction mais vous
êtes bien je pense que vous êtes
d'accord que quelqu'un qui tabasse des
citoyens quelles que soient les
circonstances
alors qu'il est déguisé en policier et
que ça relève de la justice
ça pose un problème est qu'on va pas
confier en effet des missions de
sécurité et de protection du chef de
l'état à ce personnage
or une fois qu'il a fini ses quinze
jours on le retrouve dans d'innombrables
situations on a parlé de l'arrivée des
cendres de simone veil -le au panthéon
on a parlé de la question de l'arrivée
des footballeur à paris où il est à 30
cm du chef de l'état et il est toujours
dans des missions de sécurité en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur
comment pouvez vous accepter cela et
avez vous fait des démarches pour pour
le mois vous étonné de cet état de
choses auprès de la présidence de la
république monsieur le ministre d'état
vous avez la parole
tueur d'abord si vous voulez sur la
connaissance de monsieur benalla comme
vous le savez avant d'assurer la
protection à un moment donné de la
campagne du président de la république
il avait assuré un certain nombre de
protections d'autres campagnes suis le
président hollande
de madame aubry et comme je m'étais un
peu éloigné du ps à cette époque je le
connaissais moins que d'autres et donc
voilà sur monsieur benalla sur l'article
le directeur de cabinet trempe à son
comble je te dirais que les attendait
monsieur le ministre d'état on va
rétablir le calme vous avez nous avons
pardon monsieur le ministre d'état n'ont
pas mal joué monsieur mise et ajusta
national et ministre d'état
je voudrais que vous me laissiez le soin
que la commission puisse vous entendre
dans un climat de série la gauche qui
facilite nos travaux mes chers collègues
et vous ne manquerez pas d'avoir la
parole de manière concise je le répète
est donc vous pourrez à ce moment-là
réagir je comprends que les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus par le ministre
d'état ait pu faire bondir le président
du groupe socialiste
il aura l'occasion de dire pourquoi plus
tard mais je vous demande de bien
vouloir écouter le ministre d'état dans
sa réponse donc sur l'article 40
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république vient de faire part donc
tout à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale
des éléments qui l'avait conduit à ne
pas saisir la justice de ces faits 1 le
contexte de violence et je vous rappelle
qu'elle un contexte de violence très
fort à la contrescarpe et 2 l'absence de
plainte puisque les personnes qu'on voit
sur les photos avaient pris la fuite
donc à partir de là c'est son
appréciation d'autorité hier archi et je
n'ai évidemment pas à commenter
eh bien monsieur le musée de la part de
ses deux rapporteurs je voudrais essayer
va que vaille de jouer mon rôle de
président le mieux possible et donc à ce
stade de notre audition se sont écoulés
45 minutes je pense que nous aurons
jusqu'à 20h 22h15 pour aller au bout les
questions le ministre d'état et
disponibles pour répondre à toutes les
questions
il va essayer de le faire avec lui aussi
toute la concision nécessaire il s'agit
parfois de questions très factuelle et
donc ça lui facilitera la tâche
je voudrais demander à monsieur le
rapporteur s'il a une autre question
ayant le souci aussi de permettre à
l'ensemble de nos collègues de
s'exprimer alors ce sera très concis
mais je dirais cependant à monsieur le
ministre d'état qu'il n'a pas répondu à
ma question car ma question c'est est
que dès lors que les 15 jours de
suspension on peut juger comme on veut
cette sanction c'est une sanction elle
n'était pas formalisé il n'y a pas une
procédure disciplinaire mais une option
mais que dès lors que cette sanction
était fini et est il acceptable de
confier des tâches de sécurité auprès du
chef de l'état à ce personnage question
simple monsieur la tunise l'intérieur
porté de réponse ce n'était pas
directement le ministère de l'intérieur
qui avait à gérer
il y avait effectivement c'est en
général un certain nombre d'événements
que vous avez cités qui étaient des
événements parisiens ou d'ailleurs le
préfet de police a dit qu'il était à mes
à pouvoir donc rencontré même pas à son
niveau mais des niveaux inférieurs
celui qui s'occupait de ce genre
d'événement mais effectivement moi je
n'avais pas en connaît bien monsieur le
ministre de fureur et c'est votre
réponse et le méchant tu en as bien
devoir s'en satisfaire me sens utile
pour aller que ce soit à paris ou à lui
de nancras bien traduit la négation est
la même
enfin merci monsieur je leur souli pour
moi la protection du président de la
république c'est le gspr points miami le
j'espère ce sont des policiers des
gendarmes qui dépendent aussi de
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
bien sûr mais pour nous nous ne
connaissons qu'une seule qu'une seule
autorité pour gérer la production la
protection du président de la république
le gspr merci à terminer l'étape
monsieur le rapporteur a je crois que
vous aviez terminons elle est très
courte alors l'année aux évoque la
question si la veille 3 mais elle est
très courte
vous avez hier il ya eu beaucoup de non
réponse et certains ont pu dire que vous
étiez sans doute l'une des personnes les
moins informés de notre pays ce qui
n'est pas vrai et vous avez la
possibilité de convoquer vos
fonctionnaires et de procéder à toutes
les interrogations investigations que
vous voulez donc je reste sur ma femme
par rapport à quelques questions simples
qui a donné le statut d'observateur à
monsieur benalla qui lui a donné un
brassard de police qui vraiment qu'il a
autorisé à participer à des réunions de
commandement au plus haut niveau à la
préfecture de police
et enfin eux y qui lui a donné le port
d'armes qui quelle autorité quelle
personne concrètement et enfin c'est mon
dernier point monsieur le président vous
avez dit hier que s'agissant de cette
voiture extrêmement équipés et je dois
dire que nous avons reçu les personnels
de la police
et vous le savez très bien je ne vous en
fais pas grief qui nous ont pas ce que
c'est une situation ancienne qui nous
ont fait part de
du de l'état de certains véhicules donc
un véhicule super aménagé et vous avez
dire que des je ne sais pas qui a pris
cette décision de doter ce ce monsieur
de de cela donc je pense que d'ici hier
depuis hier vous avez pu vous renseigner
merci pour les réponses précises que
vous allez apporter aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre d'état j'ai vous redonne la
parole vous voyez c'est une seule
question avec un seul point
d'interrogation mais avec beaucoup de
virgules donc je vais y répondre
comme vous le savez il y a une double
enquête à la fois judiciaire et en même
temps de l'igpn qui apportera des
réponses à ses questions en tout cas ce
que je peux vous assurer c'est que tout
ceci ne vient pas du ministère de
l'intérieur du cabinet du ministre
merci monsieur le ministre d'état
maintenant mes chers collègues le moment
tant attendu pour chacun d'entre vous
arrive vous allez pouvoir poser chacun à
son tour dans l'ordre dans lequel vous
vous êtes inscrits pendant la première
partie de cette audition votre question
nous allons pour vous aider à tenir le
temps de parole de moins d'une minute
qui vous est assignée mettre en oeuvre
le chronomètre et je donne la parole
immédiatement à monsieur françois pilet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous indiqué n'avoir saisi
l'igpn que le 18 juillet à la suite des
révélations du journal le monde
vous ne les avaient pas saisi dès lé
mois de mai dès que tout le monde était
informé des faits commis par monsieur
benalla j'y vois évidemment quelque
chose d'un peu regrettable c'est quelque
chose de très technique c'est que le 1er
mai au mois de mai n'était pas expiré
les délais de conservation des vidéos et
surtout n'était pas expiré
les délais de conservation de
l'enregistrement des conserves des
conversations entre policiers recueillis
par le système acropole or monsieur
benalla av
un téléphone qui permettait de
d'enregistrer ces conversions dans ces
têtes ou trop tard dommage mais vous
avez indique-t- cela parce que vous avez
estimé que l'igpn n'était pas compétent
au feu
mais pour autant le fait que les
policiers soient présents sur une scène
de violence commise par un observateur
paraît pouvoir être de la compétence de
l'igpn le fait que le policier chargé
d'accompagner l'observateur perd tout
contrôle sur celui ci paraît de la
compétence de l'igpn vous indiqué avoir
saisi l'igpn qu'après avoir eu
connaissance du port par monsieur
benalla du brassard de police
je ne veux pas croire que le fait de
porter le brassard de police vous
paraissent plus grave que les exactions
commises par monsieur benalla au sein
des forces de l'ordre
aussi ma question est la suivante est-ce
vos collaborateurs qui au terme d'une
analyse juridique que je trouverai un
peu fragile qui vous ont déconseillé de
saisir l'igpn qui vous ont conseillé de
tardé à saisir l'igpn
monsieur le ministre d'état que vous me
dites vous allez saisir l'igpn
tardivement
je vous rappelle que comme je voulais
indiqué le 2 mai je m'étais assuré que
la préfecture de police avait été
destinataire de l'information concernant
monsieur benalla et j'ai considéré qu'il
appartenait au préfet de police
en tant que chef de service de prendre
les mesures administratives adapté je
note d'ailleurs que le préfet de police
s'est expliqué il y est sûre les
diligences effectuées à son initiative à
ce moment-là lancement d'investigation
pour comprendre dans quelles conditions
monsieur benalla avait pu être autorisés
à assister à un service d'ordre
rappel des consignes pour que ce type de
décision remonte au bon niveau
hiérarchique
le préfet de police a par ailleurs
indiqué qu'il ne disposait pas de la
capacité à saisir l'igpn
s'agissant d'une personne qui n'était
pas placé sous son autorité
en revanche c'est à la lumière des
éléments nouveaux que j'ai jugé
effectivement particulièrement grave
parce que jusqu'à présent je vous
rappelle tout le monde pensait qu'il
avait le statut d'observateur et à
partir du moment où nous avons nous
voyons une vidéo sur laquelle il a à la
fois le brassard mais comme vous
l'indiquez éventuellement donc un
téléphone de la police
j'estime qu'effectivement il y avait un
dysfonctionnement majeur et que nous
devions saisir l'igpn ce que j'ai fait
alors non mais non excusez moi vous
poserez vos qu'elle voulait acheter sur
le bonhomme cela n'arrivera pas monsieur
mila des jeunes est pas obligé de
répondre aux interpellations des
arrivent dans le désordre
très bien 19 juillet mais posons les
questions dans l'ordre on a vraiment la
possibilité de poser toutes les
questions ne nous impatiente ont pas la
parole nous avons et à patrick kanner
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mise d'état si mes informations sont
bonnes une vidéo des manifestations du
1er mai fameuse vidéo comprenant le
passage où monsieur benalla s'en prend
physiquement à des manifestants dans les
conditions que nous savons a été
adressée à l'inspection générale de la
police nationale dès le 3 mai dernier
madame marie-france monéger guyomard sa
directrice va être auditionné par la
commission denquête mais je m'adresse à
vous en qualité de supérieur
hiérarchique de l'igpn
pouvez vous me confirmer que cette vidéo
reçue le 3 mai dernier n'a pas été
traité par les gipn dans le cadre qui
devrait être le sien et n'a pas donné
lieu à aucune enquête
avez vous été informé par l'igpn de la
réception de cette vidéo
et pourquoi n'y at il eu aucune suite
donné je profite de ce propos monsieur
le mini d'état pour vous faire part
aussi de ma réflexion personnelle qui
n'est pas lié à la provocation qui était
la vôtre il ya quelques instants bien
amical à l'égard de vos racines
politiques mais manifestement vous
êtes dans une position d'affirmer que
vous n'êtes finalement ni responsable ni
coupable ni coupable ni responsable mais
nous ne parlons pas de quelqu'un qui
achète de la vaisselle deux sèvres pour
l'elysée nous parlons de la protection
du premier personnage de l'état
comment est il possible monsieur michaud
l'état vous qui êtes si proche du
président de la république
vous qui avez côtoyé tous les meetings
du président de république que vous ne
saviez pas la place particulière occupé
par monsieur benalla et qui finalement
entache votre autorité de ministre de
l'intérieur
dans votre rôle de protection du chef de
l'état c'est une question qui nous
interpelle tous et manifestement et qui
nous inquiète manifestement votre
absence de réponse
houda réponse il consiste à dire mais
finalement je ne le connaissais pas ne
peut pas sérieusement nous satisfaire
mary ministre d'état vous avez la parole
donc j'ai su le samedi 21 juillet le
chef adjoint de l'igpn que nous avions
saisi le 18
informer mon cabinet que le 3 mai
dernier un internaute avaient
anonymement signaler la vidéo montrant
monsieur benalla intervenir place de la
contrescarpe à la plate forme de
signalement de l'igpn
cette vidéo a été analysé par les
opérateurs de la plateforme qui au vu
des images qui leur étaient soumises
n'ont pas estimé que les conditions
justifiant l'ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire étaient réunies
la plateforme ensuite enregistré aucun
signalement relatifs à ces faits ni d'un
témoin direct ni de l'une des deux
personnes faisant l'objet des
agissements en complément de l'enquêté
judiciaire
l'igpn étant saisi aujourd'hui d'une
enquête sur l'ensemble de ces faits
j'attends ses conclusions pour comprend
comment les choses se sont exactement
passé concernant ensuite à les
problématiques de sécurité
j'ai rencontré le chef du le directeur
du sdlp il y a trois jours en lui
demandant s'il lui était informée
justement des dysfonctionnements avec
monsieur benalla donc monsieur frédéric
auréal m'a affirmé qu'il n'était pas au
courant de ces dysfonctionnements
monsieur le ministre d'état vous dire
que c'est que je connais oui mais si
vous voulez au fond nous ne sommes pas
en train seulement de vouloir savoir à
quel échelon les décisions ont été
prises
nous passons beaucoup d'entre nous en
tout cas qu'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements
le mot n'est peut-être pas trop fort et
nous nous demandons comment il se fait
un petit peu comme quand il ya un
accident d'avion et c'est d'expertiser
les facteurs souvent multiples de
l'accident
comment cela at il pu être possible un
conseiller du président de la république
disposant d'une carte bleu blanc rouge
ayant ses entrées à la préfecture de
police y comptant certains amis
participent de bon coeur à une opération
de maintien de l'ordre mais beaucoup de
coeur à le voyage et vous en êtes
informés vous vérifiez que le chef de
l'état à travers ses collaborateurs en
est informé vous ne lui en parlez pas
directement en tout cas vous ne nous
avez pas dit quand vous ai posé la
question que vous lui en avait parlé et
je voulais poser plusieurs fois vous
n'allez pas sur la gravité de la
situation
l'avez-vous au moins fait vous en êtes
vous au vert au premier ministre parce
que notre problème ici c'est que la
constitution donne des pouvoirs
distinctes au président de la république
et gouvernement l'administration et la
hiérarchie d'une administration ça
dépend d'un ministre qui est placé sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et pas
celle du président de la république ce
type d'interférences crée de la
confusion dans le fonctionnement des
services publics et a profondément
bouleversé
les policiers qui nous l'ont dit est ce
que c'est ce qui ce à quoi nous serions
sensible c'est que vous nous disiez au
fond si vous avez vraiment pris
conscience très tôt de la gravité de la
situation et si vous avez eu avec le
premier ministre puisque vous n'avez pas
répondu pour la question s'adressant au
président de la république au moins la
préoccupation du bon fonctionnement
constitutionnel d'une administration
d'une hiérarchie dans laquelle on ne
peut pas tolérer d'immixion à
l'intérieur de leur hiérarchie
venant d'une autre autorité
constitutionnelle que le gouvernement
bien sûr que le président de la
république élu au suffrage universel
direct
quand il a un premier ministre
s'adossant à une majorité parlementaire
qui le soutient peu par le truchement du
gouvernement imposé indirectement son
autorité mais enfin ses collaborateurs
ne doivent pas prendre place dans une
hiérarchie parce qu'il l'a perturberait
et c'est un dysfonctionnement grave
alors excusez-moi je reviens un peu là
dessus je comprends que dans la
responsabilité politique et nous ne
sommes pas mesquinement en train de
chercher à localiser qui qui exactement
a fait quoi que l'heure où le lendemain
matin ou l'après-midi ou le soir mais
nous voulons savoir si cette
préoccupation du bon fonctionnement de
l'état et de l'administration à un
moment ou un autre été prises en compte
pour ce que cesse ce type
d'interférences monsieur le ministre
d'état monsieur le président comme je eu
l'occasion de vous le rappelez vous nous
dites il faut un retour sur les
dysfonctionnements nous aurons un retour
sur les dysfonctionnements puisque nous
avons à la fois une enquête de l'igpn n'
enquête judiciaire donc nous saurons
quels sont les responsabilités de chacun
et donc cette halle enquête judiciaire
et à lenquête de l'igpn de déterminer
les responsabilités
pour laure est ce que faisait
monsieur benalla au sein de la
présidence de la république
je crois que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république a eu
l'occasion de s'en expliquer et c'est à
lui évidemment il convient de
s'expliquer sur effectivement les tâches
qui incombaient exactement à monsieur
benalla en tout cas elle n'avait rien à
voir avec le ministère de l'intérieur et
avec ses fonctionnaires merci monsieur
le ministre d'état je prends acte de la
réponse que vous nous faites
il n'est pas dans mon pouvoir de vous
faire dire ce que vous ne voulez pas
dire et donc je n'essaierai pas plus
longtemps d'obtenir une réponse plus
précise sur la manière dont vous avez
appréhendé sur le plan politique au sens
noble du terme cette situation et sur la
manière dont elle a pu être traité au
niveau du chef du gouvernement et au
niveau du président de la république je
prend simplement acte de la réponse que
vous nous faites et je vous souligne
monsieur le président que ma réponse
était très précise à ça elle ne manquait
pas de précision absolue
alors nous allons maintenant donner la
parole à monsieur henri leroy
oui monsieur le millier d'état depuis
quelques jours nous sommes dans une
république qui vacille la fonction
présidentielle est descendu au plus bas
par une mystérieuse lésions dangereuse
du président lui-même
nous sommes confrontés à un scandale
d'état qui met en cause les principales
autorités de notre pays
j'ai écouté avec attention votre
audition d'hyères vous attribuer la
faute aux autorités de police dont vous
avez pourtant la responsabilité et pour
le reste vous ne savez rien vous n'avez
rien vu
vous n'avez rien entendu quant au
président lui qui apparaît sur toutes
les photos et donne son avis sur tout il
est soudainement muet
monsieur le ministre voici ma question
vous qui devez tout savoir qu'au
ministre l'intérieur
mais enfin qui est monsieur benalla at
il d'ailleurs un prénom quelle est sa
nationalité
j'ai lu qu'il était né dans un quartier
d'evreux quand grainé par la drogue
et la délinquance que sait-on de sa
jeunesse de son passé quels sont tous
j'ai bien dit tout ses antécédents
judiciaires
quelle a été la procédure de recrutement
de monsieur benalla enfin monsieur le
ministre lors de votre audition d'hier
vous avez dit je n'ai jamais évoqué la
situation de monsieur benalla avec le
président de la république puis quelques
minutes après à la même question vous
avez répondu j'ai rencontré le président
de la république ce week end avant nous
parler des faits le moins possible donc
vous en avait parlé
que vous êtes-vous dit réellement les
français attendent de leur ministre de
l'intérieur des réponses simples claires
et précises
merci monsieur nuit monsieur le ministre
d'état revient sur la première partie
est de votre question permettez moi de
vous dire qu'en tant que ministre de
l'intérieur je ne fais pas des oeuvres
de basse police donc je ne vais pas
examiné le passé de chacun pour regarder
s'il est issu d'un milieu populaire d'un
quartier populaire et heureusement parce
que vous seriez en droit de me le
reprocher moi je suis pour un état de
droit je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre d'état il monsieur leroy et
vous n'êtes pas satisfait de la question
mais de la réponse mais c'est celle du
ministre alors madame moustache brignon
merci monsieur malige moi je voulais
revenir un peu sur voilà le pion
monsieur benalla au milieu de quelque
chose qui nous sommes un peu floue vous
vous semblez ne pas connaître ou ignorer
qui est monsieur ménard a en tout cas ce
qu'on a appris nous après midi c'est que
beaucoup de pays s'ils connaissaient
monsieur benalla et connaissait la place
et le rôle qu'il avait ou plus haut
niveau de l'état
c'est ce qu'on a appris cet après-midi à
plusieurs syndicats de police nous on
déclare ont déclaré publiquement que
monsieur vidal avait régulièrement
participé au cours des derniers mois des
opérations de police vous avez indiqué
hier devant l'assemblée nationale ne pas
en avoir eu connaissance
avez-vous depuis hier recueilli des
informations complémentaires sur ce
point auprès de vous servent
si ce monsieur benalla at il déjà eu la
qualité d'observateurs lors d'autres
opérations de maintien de l'ordre si oui
où et quand parce que c'est important et
monsieur le ministre trouvez vous normal
qu'un adjoint au chef de cabinet du
président de la république puisse
observer ce type de manifestation et
auriez vous eu connaissance
parce qu'assez récemment il y en a eu
d'autres incidents le concernant vous
ont-ils été remontés monsieur le
ministre d'état ni à ma connaissance ni
à celle du préfet de police ni à celle
du des opc la participer à d'autres
participations va dire à d'autres faits
concernant le maintien de l'ordre mais
effectivement l'enquêté de l'igpn
l'enquète qui est menée du point de vue
judiciaire
le dira mais c'est ce qu'ont déclaré
et le préfet de police et le des opc je
n'ai pas de raison de remettre leurs
paroles en cause
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
nathalie delattre
merci monsieur le président de questions
à un briquet concise monsieur le
ministre d'état nous avons découvert la
sphère benalla grâce à la vidéo
protection les images de la vidéo pour
votre protection de paris et d'une vidéo
amateur nous apparaît dans les auditions
précédentes de l'existence de photos et
de vidéos de crs qui pourrait
s'expliquer puisqu'il était dans une
position délicate place de la
contrescarpe nous avons d'abord
découvert
monsieur alexandre benalla nous avons
ensuite découvert le commando benalla
avec monsieur vincent kraz on nous parle
maintenant d'un accompagnant monsieur
misère ce qui encadrent rendant officiel
est-ce que ses photos et ses vidéos
vont-ils avant elle nous fait
redécouvrir pardon d'autres
protagonistes sur les lieux ce que vous
avez connaissance de ces photos et que
nous font-elles visionner et pour finir
je vous demanderais s'il existe une
milice privée au sein de l'elysée
or gspr merci chers collègues aussi de
votre concision monsieur le ministre
d'énergie pour ce qui concerne monsieur
misère ce qu'est un de ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques lui demande de
l'accompagner
monsieur benalla qu'il croyait à
créditer fâché pour qu'ils croyaient
accrédités je pense mais l'enquêté
encore le montrera pour participer à une
opération de maintien de l'ordre comme
observateurs beaucoup de députés de
journalistes participent à des
opérations comme observateurs elles sont
strictement encadrées le préfet de
police l'a rappelé hier ils souhaitaient
que ce soit elle l'a rappelé à ces cas
son autorisation personnels qu'ils
soient donnés
parce que cela engage effectivement sa
responsabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur mise d'état
madame jacky d'euromédis en laisse qui
va sortir
compte tenu des deux ce qui se passe
mais j'en découvre chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je les
couvre de plus en plus et bien sûr le
ministre de l'intérieur heureusement
qu'il ya les journaux pour vous informer
alors madame d'euromédis merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre le
porte parole de l'elysée a déclaré que
monsieur benalla avait été mise à pied
pendant quinze jours avec suspension de
salaire du 4 au 19 mai est entièrement
démis de ses fonctions en matière
d'organisation de la sécurité des
déplacements du président de la
république que faisait monsieur benalla
auprès du chef de l'état au panthéon
que faisait monsieur bénalia à giverny
le vendredi 13 juillet alors qu'il avait
été déchargé de ses fonctions de chef
adjoint du cabinet sa présence dans le
quart des qui ramenait les bleus de
l'aéroport est elle normale vous
paraît-il normal qu'il ait eu des
altercations avec les policiers qui
devaient assurer cette ce retour des
bleus au à la présidence monsieur le
ministre d'état
comme vous le savez la nature démission
de monsieur benalla ce n'est pas moi qui
les fixent donc je pense que le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république s'explique raoult s'est déjà
expliqué sur l'ensemble des questions
que vous posez
merci monsieur mist état je me permets
simplement de souligner que monsieur
benalla et s'est établie s'agissant des
déplacements du président de la
république à paris étaient en contact
fréquent avec la préfecture de police ça
n'est certainement pas la préfecture de
police qui lui est assignée 7h
simplement les personnes avec lesquelles
il travaillait qui sont placés sous
votre autorité semble-t-il savait bien
ce qu'il faisait puisque elle
travaillait avec lui et par ailleurs je
suppose que les préfets les directeurs
départementaux de la police nationale
les
l'officier supérieur commandant le
groupement de gendarmerie quand il y
avait un déplacement présidentiel et
qu'il avait à traiter avec monsieur
benalla soit pour la préparation soit en
sa qualité de garde du corps supposée
est vraisemblable traitait avec lui donc
quand on vous pose ce type de question
bien entendu que c'est pas vous qui
définit si sa tâche ça je crois que
cette cette réponse nous pouvons que
vous en donner acte et simplement ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de savoir quel est
le regard porté par le ministère de
l'intérieur sur sept ce collaborateur
avec lequel vous acceptiez vos services
acceptaient de travailler sur
certainement des missions au précise cc
je crois sans vouloir sur interpréter
deux cents à la question de notre
collègue d'euromédis c'est une question
qui était purement purement factuel elle
ne vous dit pas pourquoi avez vous en
voyez monsieur benalla à giverny
mais elle vous demande est-ce que par
vos services vous avez une idée précise
de ce que monsieur benalla faisait à
giverny au nom du président de la
république met en lien avec des services
passés sous votre autorité
si je crois et excusez moi et si si je
me trompe il faut m'arrêter tout de
suite
monsieur le président mes os mais en
plus si vous voulez je voudrais quand
même il ya une partie qui vous concerne
directement ses les altercations qu'il a
eu avec les policiers
parce qu'il voulait reprendre le
contrôle du retour des bleus donc donc
ceci vous aurez vous avez certainement
été informés alors monsieur miss d'état
cette question et en étant maintenant
éclaircies monsieur le président je
travaille pour ce qui me concerne avec
les préfets qui ont la responsabilité
avec le directeur général de la police
nationale avec le directeur général de
la gendarmerie nationale et donc je ne
franchis pas cet échelon c'est à eux
d'organiser les choses comme il le
souhaite
et pour répondre à votre question
le préfet de police m'a indiqué qu'il
n'était pas informé qu'il n'aurait
jamais
quoique il l'a dit dans l'audition
qu'ils n'auraient jamais laissé prendre
le contrôle de la manifestation de
retour des bleus à quelqu'un à quelqu'un
qui soit extérieur à ses services a luz
merci monsieur le ministre d'état
monsieur pierre yves collombat pour une
minute
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état a manifestement
alexandre benalla était au ministère de
l'intérieur comme un poisson dans l'eau
un poisson plutôt carnivores d'ailleurs
semble-t-il
personne ne sait qui il est vraiment
très peu concède même le connaître
et pourtant on larmont l'équipe il
s'impose dans des opérations de maintien
de l'ordre et aux séances de débriefing
avec pour seul viatique sa réputation
d'appartenir au cabinet du président de
la république
ma question est celle-ci au final qui a
la haute main sur les services de police
et de gendarmerie en france vous
deuxième personnage de l'état dans le
respect des lois du goût du gouvernement
est donc dans le respect des lois et
règlements ou le président de la
république qui semble auto placer au
dessus des lois et règlements qui
gouvernent vous où le président de la
république qui par son influence modifie
les comportements au sein du ministère
de l'intérieur
merci chers collègues bravo pour votre
concision monsieur le ministre d'état
merci bien je viens de l'indiquer à
l'instant lorsque je fais des
débriefings comme vous dites c'est avec
les préfets nous en faisons à peu près
une tous les mois est en ce moment pour
les problèmes de terrorisme
nous faisons des débriefings avec les
préfets de zone tous les quinze jours
nous le faisons avec les directeurs de
la police nationale des directeurs de la
gendarmerie de directeur de la dgsi et
cela s'arrête là pour ce qui me concerne
je n'ai d'autre débriefing avec personne
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
di folco merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre d'état une réponse une
question très courte qui appelle une
réponse très précise
qu'auriez vous fait si l'elysée n'avait
pas indiqué réagir aux comportements
pour le moins incongru de monsieur
benalla que l'on nous vend être un
observateur voir un bagagiste merci
madame elle est folle que je me suis
simplement assuré que le directeur de
cabinet de l'elysée avait bien pris en
compte l'attitude inacceptable de
monsieur benalla et le directeur de
cabinet indiqué qu'un certain nombre de
sanctions seraient pris partir de là
c'était la sphère du directeur de
cabinet parce que c'est lui qui organise
celles et ceux qui sont effectivement
conseillé ce n'est pas au ministre de
l'intérieur d' organiser le
fonctionnement des conseillers de
l'elysée
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
brigitte lherbier
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'aurais voulu vous
poser une question concerne non
justement
les agents contractuels qui contribuent
à la sécurité des déplacements du chef
de l'état j'aurais voulu savoir si
c'était une occasion à cette occasion si
vous avez fait l'inventaire de tout ce
qui était employé at elle la présidence
at-elle recours aux services de
militants deux collaborateurs de la
république en marche pourquoi pas pour
contribuer à l'organisation ou à la
sécurité des déplacements du président
de la république
c'est une occasion de faire le point un
peu de sur le nombre sur le genre de
collaboration que les uns et les autres
peuvent avoir dans ce genre de remise
des mois comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rappeler
tout à l'heure il y a qu une seule
autorité compétente avec qui nous
traitons le gspr merci monsieur le
ministre d'état c'est votre réponse
monsieur à la marque
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je vais réitérer un petit
peu la question de notre président
philippe bas parce que nous avons
auditionné tout à l'heure des syndicats
de police et des syndicats de police un
membre de ce syndicat nous a affirmé que
monsieur benalla n'était pas tout seul
et qu'il était souvent accompagnée de
barbouzes jeu reprend les termes qui ont
été employés dans certaines émissions
vous nous avez dit qu'a priori il n'y
avait pas de police parallèle voir 2010
comme l'a dit ma collègue précédemment à
l'elysée si dans les jours qui viennent
la preuve était apportée par ces mêmes
syndicats et venant du gspr qui
apparemment était terrorisée par
monsieur benalla et qui aujourd'hui se
livre est-ce que vous trouveriez ça
normal deuxièmement monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur mise d'état 1er mai on
sait ce qui se passe mises à pied
jusqu'au 19 mai et vous qui êtes le
premier flic de france donc la personne
qui normalement devait pratiquement tout
connaître
est-ce que vous avez diligenter une
enquête
pour savoir si monsieur benalla qui se
targuait déjà de posséder un master de
droit alors je ne sais trop si c'est
vrai savoir si son casier judiciaire
judiciaire était était vierge au poste
qu'il occupait puisque la fonction
qu'effectivement il occupait la continue
d'ailleurs à occuper pouvait peut-être
pourquoi pas me lasser à terme la
sécurité du président de la république
monsieur le ministre d'état
je regrette c'est des syndicats de
police ont pu vous faire cette
déclaration qu'il ne me l'ait pas fait à
moi parce que je les rencontre assez
souvent nos discutant de l'ensemble des
problèmes et donc jamais ils ne m'ont
fait remonter de dysfonctionnements avec
monsieur benalla que jusqu'à une date
récente
je vous le rappelle je pensais qu'il
était un policier
jamais on ne m'a fait remonter ceux ci
après est ce que et à des équipes de
barbouzes pour ce qui concerne le
ministère de l'intérieur
il n'y aura jamais de barberousse
quelque part parce que effectivement
c'est quelque chose que je n'admettrai
pas il ya eu une période dans le temps
où effectivement on avait ceci c'est
vrai je l' ai connu dans ma prime
jeunesse où il y avait un certain nombre
de milices privées
moi je vais recevoir les syndicats la
semaine prochaine parce que
effectivement je pense qu'ils ont été
totalement troublée par ces événements
et je leur demanderais si devant moi ils
me disent effectivement qu'ils ont eu
des problèmes avec monsieur benalla et
je leur demanderai dans ce cas là
pourquoi il ne ment n'ont pas informé
avant
monsieur merci monsieur le ministre
d'état il ya un point sur lequel nous
convergeons c'est qu'il est absolument
indispensable d'écouter les syndicats de
policiers ans ou le mans ils nous ont
dit pour dire les choses très simplement
ils nous ont dit les langues se délient
beaucoup de gens qui se taisaient à
l'intérieur de la hiérarchie se sentent
libres de s'exprimer et donc je ne doute
pas que vous ayez très rapidement de
nombreuses informations venant du
personnel de la police sur la situation
qui était créée par les interférences de
ce collaborateur du président de la
république avec le fonctionnement normal
de l'administration plate c'est sous
votre autorité dans le cadre des
pouvoirs constitutionnels du
gouvernement qui je le répète son
distingue des pouvoirs constitutionnels
du président de la république eh bien
monsieur le président je veux simplement
vous dire et le redire qu'ils avaient
tort de ne pas faire remonter les
informations n'avaient pas parce que les
eaux montent moi parce que je suis nommé
qui les ont eu tort de ne pas faire
remonter alors ministre les informations
parce que j'aurais pris un certain
nombre de dispositions semi-état je me
suis mal exprimé
ils nous ont dit que ces informations il
les avait maintenant parce que
distillent les langues se délient
voilà ce qu'ils disent et la peur sans
doute est aujourd'hui dissipés voilà 7 c
sas et à wil élus mais j'entends
plusieurs collègues ne devrait pas les
entendre mais qui rappelle les termes
que nous avons entendu à deux reprises
la terreur oui voilà
bon alors maintenant justement c'est
madame benbassa qui va vous poser une
question
et conditions transition brrr merci
monsieur le président admettons que
monsieur le ministre ne connaissais pas
monsieur benalla ce qui est très grave
puisque celui-ci quand même s'occuper de
la sécurité du président et comme mes
collègues l'ont dit je ne sais pas
comment ça se fait que vous ne sachiez
pas que ce monsieur semer la terreur
alors je vais dans la dans la même
lancée et selon des sources policière et
syndicale à internat pour vos une
réorganisation de la sécurité de
l'elysée était dans les tuyaux mais pour
fin 2018 et avec la création d'une
direction la sécurité de la présidence
de la république composée de trois
entités
monsieur ben alla était pressenti pour
occuper une place prépondérante dans ce
dans ce dispositif directement piloté
par la présidence alors je pense que
vous ne le saviez pas non plus donc
c'est très grave puisque cela montre
ouvertement qu'il y avait une police
parallèle qui se développait à l'elysée
en parallèlement à oger espère mais
enfin ça veut dire que kylie a un vrai
dysfonctionnements dans vos services et
que vous laissez faire ce genre de
choses se soient bar blues ou autre
chose quand même
il y avait deux polices dans une privée
et l'autre pas dans à l'elysée est ce
normal
monsieur mist et à madame benbassa je ne
vous connaissez pas jusqu'à présent
cette passion pour la police mais je
suis heureux de la découvrir
pour ce qui concerne donc la réforme du
j'espère jose occasion de d'en parler
tout à l'heure je vais la compléter
simplement de la manière suivante en
disant que nous savions du côté du
ministère de l'intérieur qu'il ya d'un
projet j'avais eu l'occasion de faire
connaître mes observations président et
à son cabinet
ma principale recommandation portait sur
la nécessité de maintenir un lien
organique entre la nouvelle structure et
le ministère de l'intérieur en prévoyant
notamment que le recrutement et la
gestion du personnel resterait au
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui évite
voilà toute interprétation
l'objectif était d'éviter que la
sécurité du président ne soit
déconnectée du reste de l'état monsieur
le ministre d'état si je peux
m'autoriser un commentaire c'est une
sage recommandation
nous continuons avec monsieur j'arrive
le contre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre d'état dans la
continuité de cet échange que nous
venons d'avoir sur l'évolution de la
sécurité la présidence de la république
est-ce que je peux me permettre monsieur
le ministre de vous poser la question de
la vie que le président de la république
vous a donné en échange de ce que en
réponse aux observations que vous lui
avez fait et dont nous vous venez de
nous faire pas est ce que le président
de la république partager ou non l'avis
que vous lui avez donné sur cette
évolution de la politique de sécurité de
l'elysée
après celle mise d'état et donc les
choses à somb
bien merci monsieur le ministre d'état
savez vous si la mission qui serait
confié au secrétaire général de la
présidence de la république remet en
cause ses orientations
je n'ai pas cette information
j'espère que non parce que il me semble
que cette recommandation est tout à fait
nécessaire et qu'effectivement il faut
que ce soit le ministère de l'intérieur
qui puisse recruter les personnels je
vous remercie madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état
nous nous vivons cette séquence depuis
plusieurs jours vous sans doute plus
intensément que nous nous vous avons
entendus hier devant l'assemblée
aujourd'hui devant cette commission
vous adoptez un profil qui est un choix
puisque vous n'aviez pas connaissance de
l'existence monsieur benalla vous ne
connaissiez pas ses fonctions
vous ne saviez pas exactement quel était
son métier vous ne saviez pas très
exactement qui s'occupait de la sécurité
du président de la république vous ne
saviez pas vraiment d'ailleurs qu'il
avait été suspendue vous ne saviez pas
qu'il n'avait pas été poursuivi pour les
faits de violence bien mais vous êtes un
homme politique aguerri vous avez une
expérience très puissante
quelles conclusions tirez-vous dans
l'exercice de votre ministère de toute
cette séquence et de tous ces
dysfonctionnements ou de toute cette
absence de connaissance d'éléments parce
que forcément
j'imagine que vous avez identifié les
marges de progression incontestable qui
pouvait être accomplie et j'imagine
aussi que comme tous les ministres de
l'intérieur
j'ai travaillé avec l'un d'entre eux la
sécurité du président de la république
ait quelque chose d'obsessionnel je note
que vous n'avez pas cette obsession ce
qui est une bonne chose pour vous
néanmoins nous sommes inquiets parce que
la question du présent la république
indépendamment du fait que nous
soutenions sa politique ou pas sa
sécurité quelque chose de premier
absolument donc sur l'ensemble de ces
points quelle conclusion j'ai envie de
dire positive pouvez-vous tirer de cette
séquence pour que les choses soient
différentes et améliorer à l'avenir
monsieur le ministre d'état nous savons
que vous attendez le rapport de l'igpn
mais si déjà vous aviez quelques
orientations de principes politiques
sarah intérêts seraient certainement non
seulement madame de la gontrie mais
l'ensemble de nos collègues je vais
reprendre ce que je viens de dire à
l'instant je pense que le ministère de
l'intérieur temps effectivement sa ligne
hiérarchique est la meilleure garantie
de la sécurité à la fois de toutes les
personnalités et évidemment du président
de la république
merci de cette réponse c'est le sait
votre réponse monsieur 2007 et a annoncé
qu'il voulait madame de la gontrie
qu'effectivement il existe chez nos
policiers chez nos gendarmes dans nos
services de renseignement un sens de la
déontologie qui est fort il peut avoir
quelques manquements ici ou là mais en
général ce sont des gens que je
connaissais auparavant mais moins que
maintenant et qui font preuve dans leur
comportement d'un sang froid d'une
retenue tout à fait remarquable merci
monsieur le ministre d'état
je donne la parole à monsieur loïc hervé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état n'a toujours pas vous
nous avez indiqué que vous pensez que
monsieur benalla était policier à 26 ans
vous pensez qu'il avait quel grade par
ailleurs est ce que monsieur benalla
avait accès aux locaux du ministère de
l'intérieur et en particulier de la
place beauvau avait t'il des contacts
directs avec vous même ou avec des
membres de votre cabinet
et si oui de quelle nature étaient ses
relations enfin pour se défendre
monsieur benalla pouvait pourrait
légitimement se réfugier derrière une
forme de théories de l'apparence avec un
poste dont la dénomination laissait à
penser qu'il appartenait à
l'organigramme de la présidence de la
république
ce qui n'était pas le cas une
habilitation secret défense qui lui
était donnée un port d'armes ou avec un
grade de lieutenant-colonel de la
réserve spécialisés de la gendarmerie
nationale que pensez vous de cette
virtualité et de ses effets sur le
fonctionnement du ministère de
l'intérieur
yat-il saül à d'autres chargés de
mission bénéficions de la même
virtualité dans l'appareil d'état
merci et bonne chère collègue monsieur
mise d'état pour répondre très
précisément à votre question
donc monsieur benalla a été recruté le
25 juin 2009 en qualité de réservistes
opérationnels
il a exercé six ans dans le département
de l'eure est terminée avec le grade de
brigadier il a été radié à sa demande en
novembre 2017 et à intégrer la réserve
spécialisé au titre de son expertise en
matière de sécurité des installations et
les personnes à l'occasion de ce
changement de statut le grade de
lieutenant-colonel lui a été conférée
comme le permettent les dispositions
légales et réglementaires applicables
il ne s'agit pas d'un avancement mais
d'un nouveau statut dans la réserve
le mécanisme se rapproche de celui d'un
officier commissionné recruter un grade
données sans passer par les échelons
subalterne
le bénéfice du grade conférer se limite
au temps strictement nécessaire à
l'exécution de la mission sont
titulaires perd donc définitivement le
grade
une fois que la mission précis pour
laquelle il est mandaté est accompli
c'est en particulier les informations
que m'a donnée le général lise huret
merci monsieur le ministre d'état
mais monsieur loïc hervé vous vouliez
non je considère ne pas avoir ma réponse
sur le sur la question de savoir le
grade que vous pensiez que monsieur
benalla avait et deuxièmement sur
l'accès aux locaux du ministère de
l'intérieur place beauvau
est-ce qu'il avait commis à l'assemblée
nationale un badge lui permettant
d'accéder à la place beauvau et à votre
cabinet semeta
je n'ai jamais vu monsieur benalla au
ministère de l'intérieur
je ne suis pas toujours présent au
mais pour monsieur benalla vous ne
trouverez jamais aucune trace de
téléphone de ma part aucun envoi mail
parce que effectivement comme je voulais
dit je n'avais aucune relation avec
monsieur benalla merci monsieur le
ministre d'état
nous passons maintenant à notre collègue
jean luc fichet merci monsieur le
président monsieur monsieur le ministre
à vous entendre depuis maintenant
presque deux heures j'ai tendance à
penser que monsieur berra la lunella est
un petit génie qui est entré par
effraction dans les services de sécurité
de proximité du président de la
république il a utilisé toutes les
failles parce qu'en fait le petit génie
se révèlent être de plus en plus être un
intrus qui a su naviguer utiliser toutes
les failles pour arriver au grade de
lieutenant-colonel ce qui est quand même
très surprenant et puis devenir adjoint
au cabinet de sécurité du président de
la république
et puis agir à mon avis pas seulement
une fois mais plusieurs fois de manière
un peu rude vis-à-vis des services et
aussi dans lors de manifestations ce que
je voudrais savoir c'est à mon avis il y
as derrière tout cela un fil conducteur
il ya forcément quelque chose qui depuis
l'origine depuis 2009 nous amène au
point où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
et j'aimerais savoir si par curiosité
puisqu'il semble comme ils sont à
l'intérieur on ne voit pas en entend pas
on ne parle pas mais est ce que par
curiosité vous avez pu identifier ce fil
conducteur est ce que vous pouvez nous
dit
qui sont les personnes qui à chaque
étape on donnait les grades ont fait des
mobilisations ont attribué des cartes et
ont permis à ce monsieur de naviguer
comme il l'a fait tout à fait librement
et de circuler librement dans l'ensemble
des services de l'état
je vous remercie c'est le ministre
d'état est judiciaire de dire cela et
donc je me rangerai à la vie qui sera
exprimé lorsque nous connaîtrons
l'ensemble des faits que nous aurons
remonter tout son passé
monsieur françois bonhomme merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
depuis le début des révélations sur
cette affaire nous apprenons à la
stupéfaction générale que monsieur
benalla était partout à peu près et
surtout là où il n'avait pas à être cet
après midi notre commission a auditionné
les représentants syndicaux qui tous
nous ont fait part de la présence
récurrente de monsieur benalla de nos
mois de réunions de son rôle
autoproclamé d'un dispositif de sécurité
et des frictions que sa présence
injustifiée provoquer avec les
fonctionnaires hier monsieur gilles
blanc directeur de l'ordre public la
préfecture de paris a déclaré que
monsieur b n'avait eu aucune
autorisation pour être présent en tant
qu'observateur sur cette manifestation
monsieur ministre j'aimerais savoir
comme en qualité en charge des forces de
sécurité quelles sont les conséquences
pratiques et opérationnelles que vous en
tirez à la fois sur l'organisation et
sur la chaîne de commandement de votre
ministère de manière précise si ce
possible et puis également vous avez dit
dans mon propos liminaires sur le
déroulement des faits que vous avez
parlé de du signalement qui a été fait
des faits commis par monsieur benalla et
qui a été effectué sur une plateforme de
l'igpn le 3 mai je crois et que cette
signalement a été classée sans suite
est ce c'est le point sur lequel
j'aimerais avoir votre votre votre avis
est votre sentiment
sans que même communiste vous en seriez
informé
quel est votre sentiment à vous monsieur
le ministre précisément est pas une
analyse générale de cette situation
monsieur le ministre d'état s'il vous
plaît comme je voulais comme l'indiquait
monsieur gibelin lui-même il ne savait
pas que ce jour là monsieur benalla
était en mission sur le service d'or
c'est ce qui a amené un certain nombre
de sanctions qui ont été prises par le
préfet de police et donc si eux ne
savaient pas à leur niveau
évidemment que le ministre de
l'intérieur ne pouvait pas savoir
donc moi je j'ai évidemment l'émission
je les ai fini avec le préfet de police
rarement d'ailleurs avec des niveaux
inférieurs et donc c'est à eux que je
m'adresse et ceux qui ont la
responsabilité de leurs troupes alors
après comme l'a dit le préfet de police
hier qu'il y ait eu effectivement et du
copinage
je crois que le préfet de police en a
déjà tenu qu'on qu'il a prononcée f
qu'il a prononcée il m'a proposé un
certain nombre de sanctions que nous
avons acceptée et que sur la
redéfinition du dispositif de la pp il
aura un certain nombre de leçons à tirer
merci monsieur mise d'état monsieur la
plateforme gérée précieux pour nos
malheurs ce que j'ai su hier samedi
pardon samedi seulement
donc ce n'est jamais remonté au niveau
du ministre du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur n'est à son directeur de
quesnoy je vous signale que des faits
comme cela il y en a des centaines et
des centaines que nous avons plusieurs
plateformes d'information et
qu'évidemment les plateformes de
signalement ne remonte pas tout
évidemment ni au ministre de l'intérieur
ni même à son directeur de la police
comme je vous l'indiquais tout à l'heure
il y à une hiérarchie où chacun
est responsable de ce qui se passe dans
son service merci monsieur me l'état je
veux redire ici que c'est précisément
parce que nous aussi nous sommes
attentifs à ce que la hiérarchie interne
au ministère de l'intérieur soit
respecté que nous sommes très inquiets
des interférences qui nous ont été
signalés avec le fonctionnement de cette
hiérarchie par l'intrusion d'un
collaborateur du président de la
république
c'est dire que nous poursuivons d'une
certaine façon de même objectif éviter
que la hiérarchie soit perturbé par
cette ce type d'intrusions qui génère
une confusion des pouvoirs entre la
présidence de la république et des
responsabilités du ministre et du
gouvernement qui ne sont pas de même
nature
alors madame le rapporteur me demande la
parole merci monsieur président monsieur
le ministre je crois qu'à ce stade pour
rebondir sur les propos du président
philippe bas nous sommes d'accord sur
plusieurs points la sécurité du
président de la république et tout
seulement essentiel pour chacun d'entre
nous ici pour vous aussi bien évidemment
je crois que nous sommes bourrés
d'accord aussi sur le fait qu'elle doit
être assurée par le ministère de
l'intérieur ce que vous avez répété avec
force tout à l'heure nous avons tous
constaté que l'intrusion de monsieur
benalla a mis à mal ce principe vous
êtes vous assurer que le cas benalla
était bien un cas isolé dans la
protection du président de la république
monsieur le ministre d'état
dans la suite évidemment vous avez
raison la protection du président de la
république est quelque chose d'essentiel
et c'est pour cela je voulais dit tout à
l'heure que nous disions que le gspr
devait être le seul garant de la
sécurité du président de la république
et devait voir ces fonctionnaires
recrutés par le ministère de l'intérieur
et donc dans la réforme qui était
envisagé pour regrouper les deux forces
nous dit que l'autre c'est lé commandant
de crs et nous voulions que cela reste
sous la responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur
pas c'est la meilleure garantie que les
choses se passent bien et donc c'est ce
qui avait été décidé
merci monsieur mise et à monsieur
françois pilet veut rebondir sur votre
réponse sur votre réponse rebondissait
chers collègues car vous avez affirmé à
l'assemblée que le projet de réforme de
la protection présidentielle qui est par
fusion du j espère avec le commandement
militaire de l'elysée pour dire que pour
créer une direction de la protection du
président serait uniquement et vous nous
l'avez dit à l'heure uniquement piloté
par les chefs de ces deux entités en
voie de rapprochement
or curieusement le contrat du travail de
monsieur benalla que je vais vous citer
montrent qu'il s'est vu confier je cite
une mission de coordination de la
sécurité avec les forces militaires et
le groupe de sécurité de la présidence
de la république autrement dit le gspr
comment pourriez vous ignorer
l'existence de cette mission qui
contredit un peu ce que vous souhaitez
cette mission qui confirme monsieur
benalla concernant le gspr qui est un
service qui sous votre autorité et dont
l'activité
comme vous venez de le dire est
particulièrement sensible maintenez-vous
toujours devant le sénat que monsieur
benalla n'a pris aucune part à ce
rapprochement
contrairement d'ailleurs l'intitulé de
sa mission je suis ne sais pas ce qui
se passait entre les deux responsables
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
ministère de l'intérieur a toujours dit
et donc fait prévaloir le fait que le
ministère de l'intérieur était le
meilleur garant de la sécurité du
président et que cela devait être ainsi
pour le reste sur le contrat ce n'est
pas le ministère de l'intérieur qui
rédige les contrats des conseillers de
l'elysée bien merci de cette réponse et
de cette question madame marie mercier
oui mais monsieur le ministre d'état
vous avez bien compris que nous
cherchons en fait nous nous cherchons à
faire toute la lumière sur cette affaire
qui comme vous avez pu le lire choc
huit français sur dix je voudrais
revenir sur le déroulement des faits
parce que nous avons comme les
journalistes déceler des incohérences
entre vos déclarations et celles de
monsieur delpech sur la manière dont
l'information sur la sphère benalla vous
est remonté le 2 mai vous nous avez dit
avoir été mis au courant le 2 mai à 15
heures de cette affaire est ce que vous
pouvez préciser comment vous avez été
mis au courant
parti sur l'effet de cette violence
commis par monsieur benalla
tout à l'heure par mon directeur de
cabinet qui m'a dit qu'il avait informé
donc le directeur du cabinet de la
présidence oui mais comment parce qu'il
avait eu les vidéos parce que de quelle
manière exactement comment lui le
savait-il comment lui le savent et il
nous avait correspondu le matin entre le
préfet de police lui même qui
découvraient les uns les autres ce qui
s'était passé
c'est ce qui effectivement m'a été dit
dès le matin on directeur été informée
le dire
le préfet de police a été ensuite
j'étais avec lui comme je voulais 10 sur
les lieux où s'était déroulée la
manifestation
à cette heure-là il ne m'a pas informé
des circonstances qui s'était passé la
veille
merci messieurs le ministre d'état s'est
maintenant monsieur françois grosdidier
dont je rappelle qu'il vient de rendre
public un rapport extrêmement important
qui lui a permis d'être au contact des
forces de sécurité il est depuis
longtemps mais tout particulièrement au
cours des derniers mois et ce rapport a
permis de faire un état des lieux à peu
près complet à la fois sur le moral des
troupes et les moyens qui sont mis à la
disposition des effectifs de police et
de gendarmerie
les syndicats de policiers nous ont dit
tout à l'heure combien ce travail de
senna avait recueilli un très large écho
en leur ca et combien ils approuvaient
le diagnostic qui a été présentée par
monsieur grosdidier mais vous le savez
monsieur le ministre d'état vous avez
naturellement eu communication de ce
rapport monsieur grosdidier
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre d'état le président faisait
référence au travail que nous avons mené
depuis six mois pour juger de l'état des
forces de sécurité intérieure et j'en ai
le même malaise quand je vous rencontre
j'ai l'impression que nous
voyons pas la même réalité que nous ne
que vous vivez dans une bulle
c'est le sentiment que j'avais lorsque
vous ne percevez vielles pas le profond
malaise des policiers c'est le sentiment
que j'ai toujours quand vous nous
expliquer en début de séance que vous
avez noué le lien avec les les policiers
et ne renouer le lien avec les policiers
notamment avec les syndicats alors que
nous sortions d'une audition avec les
syndics en ayant entendu entre tous les
collègues est exactement le le contraire
donc audrey vous ramener à cette réalité
notamment si vous connaissez votre
ministère on ne peut pas se contenter de
réponses qui paraissent dilatoires et
qui renvoie à le résultat de l enquête
judiciaire ou de l' enquête
administrative de l'igpn pour savoir des
choses toutes simples qu'on doit
connaître dans votre ministère il suffit
que vous demandiez ce soir pour avoir
normalement la réponse demain
si le ministère fonctionne on vous a
posé la question du véhicule quoi on on
ne va pas on sait qu'ils donnent des
véhicules et qui les a coincés traçable
personne vient se servir au garage en
véhicules de police et repart avec sûr
personne ne l'ait vu quoi il y à des
procédures il suffit que vous demandiez
pour la boire on n'a pas besoin dit j'ai
peine donc si vous ne savez pas de ce
soit vous devez pouvoir nous le dira
paraître demain ou dans un de vos de vos
collaborateurs le dise de la même façon
pour le port d'armes
vous auriez parait-il refusé deux fois
le port d'armes
alors pour quelle raison la préfecture
de police peut-être donner un port
d'armes qui a été refusé deux fois par
la ministère de l'intérieur donc déjà on
évoqué l'organisation un peu ennuyeux
d'orgue qui nuit d'ailleurs à la
cohérence de la police ça en serait une
une nouvelle illustration mais faisait
savoir qui a donné le port d'armes e et
et pourquoi
de la même façon pour le brassard qui
était le tuteur à ce moment-là de
l'observateur
alexandre benalla c'est forcément lui
qui lui a donné ou qui doit de savoir
comment il a eu le brassard quoi il n'ya
pas besoin d'attendre des semaines une
le résultat de l'igpn si vraiment vous
savez ce qui se passe e
dans vos dans votre maison enfin je
demanderai comment pensez vous que
peuvent recevoir en plus pris gilles
conclut policiers et gendarmes
les informations sur le véhicule neuf
sur le logement même s'ils relevaient de
l'elysée alors que on l'a parfaitement
décrit policiers et gendarmes vivent
dans des rôles dans des voitures qu'en
moyenne 8 en moyenne d'âge
parfois les métiers danger de en danger
ou sont aussi relogés dans des logements
obsolète et et est souvent indignes
alors voilà ces informations que l'on
vous demande où il devrait pouvoir nous
les donner sans attendre
l'enquète de l'igpn donc j'aimerais d
avoir ce soir ou peut-être demain merci
monsieur grosdidier
mes chers collègues je vous demande de
m'excuser du favoritisme dont monsieur
grosdidier a fait l'objet il a eu double
temps de parole mais en fait ils le
méritaient bien à la suite du travail
qu'il a réalisé et les autres n'ont plus
qu'à en faire autant alors monsieur le
ministre d'état vous avez la parole
monsieur vos idées à placer le débat mon
avis au niveau ils méritent de se poser
c'est à dire les moyens de
fonctionnement de nos services de police
de nos services de gendarmerie de nos
services de renseignement
et depuis que je suis arrivé je me bats
effectivement pour que nos policiers et
nos gendarmes et nos services de
renseignement ait les moyens de
travailler
je vous rappelle et j'avais montré je
crois est certain nombre de courbes que
jusqu'en 2012
il ya une déperdition terrible du nombre
de policiers de gendarmes qu'à partir de
2012 ça
ça a commencé vous me permettez ça
commençait à réaugmenter vous demandez
de quoi on s'occupe
eh bien on s'occupe de cela de pouvoir
faire en sorte que nous policiers
aujourd'hui il est la capacité à
utiliser des tablettes à utiliser des
smartphones aviv dans des commissariats
des sens bref avoir les moyens de
travailler
c'est cela le travail du ministre de
l'intérieur et en particulier de faire
en sorte que sur les choix budgétaires
qui sont faits qui ne sont pas simples
aujourd'hui la police la gendarmerie et
les services de renseignement aient les
moyens de travailler mais alors mais
monsieur mais s'il vous plaît monsieur
attendait monsieur mise et à monsieur
grosdidier
à la décharge du ministre d'état
je lui dis avec beaucoup d'amitié votre
question était longue
si bien qu' il pouvait effectivement
avoir et comment dire le sentiment qu'il
répondait à votre question alors que
vous avez le sentiment qu'il ne
répondait pas voulez vous nous dire en
15 secondes en trois mots seulement qui
a donné quoi et éventuellement quand
bien merci monsieur cet article que va
démontrer à la fois
l'enquète judiciaire l enquête de l'igpn
en tout cas ce n'est pas le ministère de
l'intérieur qui a effectivement donné
ses brassards et qui a donné ce
téléphone et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
quand nous avons vu cela que nous avons
saisi l'igpn
mes chers collègues nous passons
maintenant à monsieur éric kerrouche
parce que c'est merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
à vrai dire nous aussi nous préférerions
que vous soyez à votre place au
ministère de l'intérieur plutôt qu'ici
vous l'avez compris
néanmoins vous nous dites que vous ne
connaissez pas monsieur benalla
simplement quelques faits pour aller
assez vite
il me semble difficile actuellement
d'échappée ou plus exactement de trouver
une photo des manuels macron sans
alexandre benalla les derniers moments
dans la presse nous l'ont montré
par ailleurs il me semble que vous avez
été un membre éminent de la campagne du
candidat emmanuel macron et il me semble
également que votre actuel chef de
cabinet monsieur girier était également
l'un des directeurs de campagne d'
emmanuel macron et il me semble que dans
cette campagne j'avais cru comprendre
que monsieur b dallas était en charge
directement de la sécurité des manuels
macron donc première question monsieur
le ministre
est ce que vous comprenez notre
étonnement quand vous nous dites que
vous ne connaissez pas du tout monsieur
benalla ça c'est le premier point est le
deuxième poids et il est lié aux
premiers si vous ignoriez complètement
les fonctions et la personnalité de
monsieur benalla est ce que vous trouvez
normal dans ce cas là que la présidence
de la république désigne a chargé de
mission pour venir s'immiscer dans les
missions de la police dans l'émission de
votre ministère autre que la sécurité du
président voilà monsieur le ministre est
à lorsque il y avait la campagne
électorale toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont fait les campagnes électorales
ici le savent pour les candidats à la
fois une protection policière et en même
temps un certain nombre de militants et
assure le service dans ce qui fait
beaucoup de monde comme je voulais dit
j'ai toujours cru que monsieur benalla
était effectivement un policier et il y
avait d'autres policiers je pense pas
campagne chargé de la protection et donc
dans les grands meetings
moi je n'ai jamais
l'occasion de savoir qui était
effectivement policiers et qui n'étaient
pas policier était simplement bénévoles
donc cela ne me concernait pas j'ai
essayé de porter des idées
ça peut paraître bizarre aujourd'hui de
porter un certain nombre d'idées mais
voilà je portais des idées pendant cette
campagne
pensant que la france avait besoin de
changer que nous avions besoin de nous
réunir
voilà c'était ça ma ligne politique moi
je n'ai jamais fait d oeuvre de basse
police durant les vingt ans qui viennent
de s'écouler et je n'en ferai pas plus
dans le futur
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
harribey merci monsieur le président
j'aimerais j'aimerais comprendre
monsieur pour vous monsieur benalla
était policier mais en même temps il y a
eu deux demandes de port d'armes qui ont
été refusés au ministère de l'intérieur
avant qu'ils soient obtenus par la
préfecture de police
donc comment on peut ne pas être alertés
par le fait de refuser un port d'armes
en même temps à quelqu'un que l'on croit
policiers etc votre cabinet a priori qui
a en juin 2010 est effectué un refus
deuxième question
pouvez-nous nous donner les motifs de ce
refus et en quoi les motifs de ce refus
ne vous ont pas conduit à une certaine
surveillance et à une alerte vis-à-vis
du président de la république je reviens
à la question de départ qui a été
présenté par notre président sur la
gestion politique de cette affaire
monsieur mise et a alors comme je
voulais dit moi je croyais que monsieur
benalla était policier mais vous le
comprendrez bien ce n'est pas moi qui ai
souri directement les ports d'armes donc
je vais vous dire comment les choses se
passent monsieur benalla a sollicité à
plusieurs reprises les services du
ministère de l'intérieur pour obtenir
une autorisation de port d'armes
je voulais ni la première fois c'était
en 2013
et en janvier 2017 et enfin en juin 2017
auprès de mon cabinet toutes ces
demandes ont été refusées car monsieur
benalla ne remplissait pas les
conditions requises exposé c'est-à-dire
exposition à des risques exceptionnels
d'atteinte à sa vie pour se voir
délivrer une telle autorisation
ministérielle en 2013 comme en 2017
ces demandes ont été instruites
conformément à la procédure habituelle à
savoir instruction par la dlp agit le
service juridique du ministère puis à
vis de plusieurs services renseignements
territoriale du clap et à vis de la dgpn
alors que les avis et services étaient
défavorables
mes prédécesseurs et moi même avons
refusé la délivrance d'une autorisation
le port d'ars toutefois comme je voulais
indiqué par un arrêté du préfet de
police du 13 octobre 2017
monsieur benalla s'est vu délivrer une
autorisation de port d'armes sur un
autre fondement du code de la sécurité
intérieure sans que mon cabinet n'ont
été avisée je l' ai découvert mercredi
dernier merci monsieur de ministre
d'état
les membres de la commission des lois
qui s'étaient inscrits ont tous pu poser
leurs kits leurs questions et je vous
propose maintenant de prendre la
question de trois collègues qui ne sont
pas membres de la commission des lois
que je rappelle que vos questions vont
être posées sous le statut de sénateur
et pas sur celui de membre de la
commission des lois avec les pouvoirs
d'investigation d'une commission
denquête voilà alors monsieur pierre
laurent oui ma question porte sur les
incohérences de vos nouveaux
déclarations sur le ministre d'état
votre principal collaborateur depuis des
années à lyon qui vous a suivi du 9e
arrondissement à la métropole et qui est
aujourd'hui votre chef de cabinet jean
marie cherrier a été directeur de
campagne d'emmanuel macron c'est lui
qui a recruté monsieur benalla fin 2016
comment pouvez-vous dans l'équipe de
campagne de maquereaux comment
pouvez-vous prétendre vu votre proximité
personnelle avec monsieur girier ne pas
connaître monsieur benalla deuxièmement
le l'officier de police
le fonctionnaire de police delà des opc
appartenant à l'état major monsieur
philippe misère ce qui a déjà été évoqué
dans certaines auditions qui est
semble-t-il le tuteur de monsieur
benalla qui est lui aurait remis les
attributs de police n'a pas été mis en
examen alors que trois autres policiers
ont été mis en examen
est ce qu'est ce qui nous garantit que
le système de copinage dont vous avez
vous même parler ou donc à parler
monsieur delpech et qui aurait protégé
monsieur benalla ne va pas perdurer dans
le système de sanction qui est en train
de se mettre en place et enfin
maintenez-vous envers et contre tout ce
que nous avons entendu de la part des
syndicats de policiers ce matin que rien
ne vous est remonté sur les relations
exécrables
je reprends une expression d'index
syndicats de policiers et les incidents
récurrents qui existerait entre monsieur
benalla et les services de police même
si les langues se délient tardivement on
a du mal à croire que dans la hiérarchie
policière personne n'entendait parler de
ces incidents
vu le nombre visiblement d'incidents
qu'il y a eu et qui nous ont été
rapportés ce matin par les syndicats de
policiers visiblement on ne serait pas
tout donc comment est ce possible que
aucune de ces informations ne vous soit
parvenu ne vous soit jamais remonté
monsieur le ministre d'état
ont dû à toutes les questions que vous
me posez je vous rappelle que monsieur
misère ce qui était toute heure de
monsieur benalla qu'il a désigné comme
tuteur c'est ce que dira effectivement
l'enquète de ligier f et l'enquète
judiciaire qui est en cours
[Musique]
merci monsieur sûr nous agirions vous
n'avez rien à dire tu re monsieur juriez
je ne pense pas qu'il ait jamais recruté
monsieur benalla il devait donc en être
ainsi
il y aurait des questions de confiance
nous prenons acte de cette réponse
monsieur le ministre d'état et madame
laurence rossignol va vous poser une
question
merci monsieur le président est monsieur
le ministre d'état le 2 mai vous
découvrez que monsieur benalla que vous
connaissez au moins de vue puisque la
vie au soir vous avez échangé avec lui
une accolade dans votre propre ministère
nous avions une accolade avec lui la
veille au soir à la préfecture pardon à
la préfecture vous découvrez que cet
homme n'est pas policier comme vous le
pensiez et vous découvrirez en même
temps que il s'est livré au cours d'une
manifestation à des actes qui sont
souvent qualifiés de violences
policières et qu'en tant que tel on
aurait donc attribué à des policiers des
violences qui ne viendraient pas de
policiers puisqu'elles viennent un homme
qui n'est pas policier à ce moment là
j'imagine que vous vous avez vous êtes
dit qu'il y avait une situation qu était
à la fois préjudiciable à l'image de la
police puisqu'un homme frappe des
manifestants la vidéo circule pendant
des jours et des jours
et cet homme n'est pas un policier et en
même temps comme vous découvrez qu'il
n'est pas policier mais que c'est un
collaborateur du président de la
république il est possible que vous
soyez dit aussi que son comportement
mettait également en danger le président
de la république
la preuve d'un certain point de vue
qu'avez vous fait à ce moment là pour
protéger à la fois les services de
police elle présente la république des
agissements de
benalla indépendamment du fait que vous
ayez prévenu la présidence de la
république
en attendant puisque en attendant le 18
juillet vous n'entendrez plus parler de
monsieur benalla est ce que pendant ce
temps là monsieur benalla en fait tu
pourrais continuer d'agir comme il avait
agi précédemment ou est ce que vous
pourriez des mesures pour qu'il cesse
ses gestes ses agissements c'est le miz
étape pour réponse d'abord je veux vous
dire que je ne sais pas de vous tenez un
certain nombre d'informations le préfet
de police a précisé hier lors de son
audition qu'il avait été extrêmement
surpris moi aussi de voir cette personne
là qu'il n'avait jamais donné
l'autorisation et qu'il n'y avait jamais
eu d'accolade que j'avais simplement
situer la quarantaine salué la
quarantaine de personnes qui se
trouvaient dans la salle de commandement
et que nous étions surtout les yeux
fixés sur ce qui se passait à la
contrescarpe ou comme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure ce qu'on oublie un peu
cet arrière-plan les violences
continuaient et qu'un certain nombre de
personnes étaient en train de prendre le
matériel urbains où seul le matériel
vert et blanc pour faire des barricades
ou pour agresser les policiers ça c'est
le contexte
quant à dire que et c'est souvent livrés
à ça je n'en sais strictement rien celle
enquête policière et la enquête
judiciaire par donc il le montrera et
nous verrons effectivement ce qui est
prouvé moi je vais répondu tout à
l'heure je ne sais pas si par le passé
il ya eu d'autres faits l'enquète le
montrera la fois léger pnl enquête
judiciaire
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
bonfanti dossat merci monsieur le
président au fond monsieur le ministre
l'important est me semble qu'il ce que
ressent le peuple français depuis ses
révélations ce peuple français qui a
grandement besoin d'être rassuré un
proverbe politique qui nous vient des
états unis nous dit ce n'est jamais le
crime lui-même qui causent le scandale
ce sont les manoeuvres pour le
dissimuler
alors ma question monsieur le ministre
sera simple y aura-t-il y at il une
tentative manifeste d'étouffer ce
scandale monsieur le ministre à une
question claire
moi j'ai toujours dit que le ministère
de l'intérieur faisait son travail qu'il
y avait un certain nombre de gens pour
faire leur travail
je vous ai dit dgpn dggn services de
renseignement service de sécurité
préfecture de police que c'était à eux
de faire remonter les dysfonctionnements
effectivement de les résoudre
si le constate c'est toujours la
position du ministère de l'intérieur
moi je suis un ministre républicain je
ne compte que sur les forces légales
pour résoudre les problèmes de ce pays
et même lorsqu'il ya des manifestations
d'une violence inouïe
je pense que c'est la police
républicaine qui doit effectivement
assurer le maintien de l'ordre
ça a toujours été ma position et ça le
sera toujours
[Musique]
merci monsieur le ministre d'état
sauf si l'un d'entre vous demande à
poser une question je vais donner la
parole à cédric perrin pour la dernière
question de cette audition monsieur oui
c'est un merci monsieur le président tu
perds à un sénateur du territoire de
belfort
merci monsieur le président et
vice-président de notre commission de la
défense les affaires étrangères j'ai une
petite question sur laquelle j'aimerais
qu'on revienne monsieur le précieux le
ministre si vous écoutez la question
j'ai une petite question parce que je
suis très étonné parce que c'est pas non
à nombreuses reprises le président de la
commission des lois vous a posé la
question de l'article 40 et de la raison
pour laquelle vous n'êtes pas intervenue
suite à la connaissance des faits pour
mettre en oeuvre cet article 40 et vous
nous répondez à peu près
systématiquement vous l'avez fait à
l'assemblée nationale comme vous l'avez
fait ici aujourd'hui vous nous répondez
systématiquement est ce que je peux
comprendre qu'il y a tellement de faits
qui pourraient être signalé que vous ne
l'avez pas jugé utile
très bien nous en prenons acte mais
monsieur le ministre moi j'aurai une
simple question combien d'après à votre
connaissance puisque c'est le terme qui
est très utilisé ce soir à votre
connaissance monsieur news combien de
d'actes délictueux susceptibles de
pouvoir être de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
l'article 40 ont été commis par des
membres du cabinet du président de la
république s'il vous plaît ces dix
dernières années monsieur le ministre
d'état et déjà répondu à cette question
disons qu il ne m'appartenait pas pour
les raisons que j'ai déjà indiqué de
mettre en oeuvre l'article 40 et je vous
ai rappelé que les ministres de
l'intérieur du passé ont fait un usage
de l'article 40 qui était simplement
mais bien de moi à la fois donc des
actes concernant le droit de la presse
ou des actes effectivement de torture
j'ai par exemple pour monsieur brice
omis par des actes de cabinet pour me
moody cap de feu j'ai à la fois donc un
délit sur la question le ministre
la diffusion de cette vidéo se torturent
guéant ma question est douce sur le
délit de contestation de crimes contre
l'humanité et provoqué membres du
cabinet l'oeil dans l'acrylique vidéo
une chanson intitulée révisionnistes de
délit de provocation à la violence sur
le site copwatch
moi je fais mon travail la personne
relève du cabinet du président de la
république
j'informe le mon directeur de cabinet
informe le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république qui dit que
les sanctions seront pris et que
effectivement ces faits sont
inacceptables
je suis ensuite moi consacrer à d'autres
tâches
je vous rappelle que des lendemains nous
avions des manifestations à peu près à
gérer dans toute la france que le 5 mai
une autre manifestation était prévue à
paris qui aurait pu entraîner les mêmes
troubles
à partir du moment où le directeur de
cabinet est informé par mon directeur de
cabinet et qu'il a dit je les prises en
compte
je pense que les faits sont prises en
compte monsieur perrin redemande la
parole car il souhaite avoir une
précision complémentaire je crois non
non monsieur le président je vais pas de
réponse non comme comme à l'essentiel
des questions de société construire
alors monsieur le ministre d'état nous
allons mettre un terme à cette audition
mais je vais vous dire avant que nous
nous séparions que en vertu des pouvoirs
qui nous sont dévolues par les sénats
unanime nous allons vous écrire
bien sûr vous avez fait un certain
nombre de réponses de les avons
enregistré mais il ya un certain nombre
de points qui pour les rapporteurs et
moi-même restent obscures nous allons
donc vous poser de nouvelles questions
par écrit vous demander comme nous avons
le droit de le faire
des documents et je voulais vous en
prévenir
avant que nous nous séparions car ce
sont nos attributions et nos compétences
qui s'exerceront à travers ces demandes
que nous allons vous faire monsieur le
président je répondrais bien évidemment
mais je veux souligner que mes réponses
ont été extrêmement précis sur
l'ensemble des points mais que si sur
tel ou tel point
vous aviez effectivement des demandes à
me faire qu'ils ne soient pas couverts
par l'anc est judiciaire qui est
aujourd'hui menée je vous y répondrait
bien volontiers ce sera nécessairement
le cas monsieur le ministre d'état car
nous prenons grand soin de réserver les
compétences de l'autorité j'utilise
judiciaire qui s'exerce sur des
questions ponctuelles
alors que nous posons des questions
relatives à l'administration et aux
aides aux institutions c'est bien le
mandat que nous avons reçu